Good morning everyone. My name is Mary Ann Meade Ward, Mayor of the City of
Burlington and I'd like to call to order this regular meeting of Burlington
City Council for Tuesday February 17, 2026. I'll now read a safety notice for
all those in council chambers. In the event of an emergency please evacuate
the council chambers by the nearest exit staircase which is located through the
doorway marked with the exit symbol. Once you've evacuated the building please
gather in Civic Square outside of City Hall. I'll now read a land acknowledgement.
Burlington as we know it today is rich in history and modern traditions of many
First Nations and the Métis. From the Anishinaabeg to the Haudenosaunee and
the Métis, our land spanning from Lake Ontario to the Niagara escarpment are
steeped in Indigenous history. The territory is mutually covered by the
Dish with One Spoon Wampum Belt Covenant, an agreement between the Iroquois
Confederacy, the Ojibwe and other allied nations to peaceably share and care for
the resources around the Great Lakes. We would like to acknowledge that the land
on which we gather is part of the treaty land and territory of the
Mississaugas of the Credit. I'll now ask all those willing and able to please
stand for the national anthem.
Oh Canada, our home and native land, true patriot love in all of us command.
Car ton bras sait porter l'épée, il sait porter la croix. Ton histoire est une épopée des plus brillants exploits.
God keep our land glorious and free. Oh Canada, we stand on guard for thee.
Oh Canada, we stand on guard for thee.
City of Burlington committee and council meetings are live webcast and archived on
the city's website. Today's meeting is being captioned digitally through our
agenda management software and I'd like to remind participants attending
virtually to use headphones or a microphone and all of us to speak
clearly so our words can be captured accurately. We do have rules of
engagement in council meetings and we ask everyone to be respectful while
others are speaking. Listen as you would want to be listened to. By way of
introduction of our members our first order of business for today's meeting is
a roll call. I'll turn it now to the City Clerk who will take attendance of
members present and confirm quorum. Go ahead. Thank you Mayor Meadward.
Councillor Galbraith? Present. Councillor Kearns? Present. Councillor Nielsen? Here.
Councillor Stolti? Present. Councillor Sharman? Here. Councillor Bentavanya? Present. Mayor
Meadward? Present. There is a quorum. Excellent. Staff joining today are our
Chief Administrative Officer Kurt Benson, our City Clerk Mike Durand, Clerk's
Assistant Debbie Hordyke, Audiovisual Specialist David Thompson and Richard
Belmere and other staff will be introduced as their items are discussed.
Our meeting is scheduled today until 12, reconvening at 1 and going till 4 30
should we need all of that time. Does anyone have a hard stop prior to the
end? Councillor Kearns go ahead. Hard stop at lunch for a constituent meeting. Okay
thank you. Any other? Go ahead Councillor Nielsen. I don't know if it matters but
I'll be at I'll be serving pancakes for show of Tuesday at 5 o'clock so there you
go. Okay I hope we're done by 5. We're scheduled till 4 30. Okay we do have a
late request, two late requests to delegate. David Barker regarding options
for the temporary elimination of development charges DGM 326 and
Shannon Gillies regarding heritage response to Bill 23 phase 2 shortlist of
designation candidates. We do need to move, waive the rules of procedure to
allow these two to speak so I would ask Councillor Stolti would you like to move
that we hear from them? Yeah okay well let's get it moved first.
Okay Councillor Sharma would you like to second? Okay you had a question go ahead
Councillor Stolti. Yeah I had a procedural question for the clerk and it
was in regards to some information that was shared over the course of the long
weekend about when the agenda for today was made public and how that may have
impacted residents ability to delegate and I think it's relevant in the
request today to for a late delegation that now requires us to move on that
procedurally. Certainly through you Mayor Meadward so yes the agenda was later
than obviously we would have liked it to be on Friday afternoon and because
of the holiday Monday yesterday the the delegation deadline reverted to the
Friday at noon so the agenda was issued after the delegation deadline which is
obviously not ideal for us so any any requests that did come in throughout the
weekend we did forward to council and let them know that let the delegates
know that there would be an opportunity for council to waive the procedure by
a lot to have them added but yes going back to Friday it was the issue later
than we would have liked it to be. Just so as a point of clarity was there a
messaging put on the city website along with that agenda to let everyone in the
public know that there was the opportunity to come to council and
register late? Through you Mayor Meadward no there wasn't that's certainly
something that we would do going forward. So the delegates who are here today
requesting to delegate with a late request are only because they happen to
know our procedural bylaw that that's available to them but the general public
wouldn't have known that. Through you Mayor Meadward yes I think that's fair
to say. Okay thank you. Councillor Kranz? Through the mayor thank you Councillor
Silke for some of those earlier comments my hand took a minute to be recognized.
My question is to the clerk is this the complete list of the late registered
delegates? I believe there might be one more and I just want to be certain that
we've captured everyone or that this amendment allows everyone to speak who
wishes to speak. Through you Mayor Meadward this is the late this is the list that was
submitted to the clerk's email after the Friday afternoon. Okay so maybe I will do
a follow-up then I do have an email here saying hello yesterday morning I sent
the delegation form for DGM 0306 I will be there in person I don't have slides
or notes can I be recognized can is that person here do we know this was sent to
the clerk's mailbox? They're coming later for 10. So if we pass this procedure by
law amendment does it allow everyone who wants to speak to speak or just those on
the script? It would be that's through you Mayor Meadward it would just be the
people that are mentioned in the amendment or the the request to waive
the procedure by law amendment I think that we could whether the add the third
person to the motion just to be safe to have them delegate but unfortunately we
didn't we didn't receive that. Okay would you like a minute to check the clerk's
mailbox to see if there's anyone else or would you like the name of the
individual that's asked to be added to the list? We'd take a minute to check the
mailbox. Okay we'll take a five minute recess. Thank you. Reconvening at quarter
to ten.
you
all right folks we are back from our recess I will turn it to the clerk and
go to the two hands that are on the board go ahead. Thank You Mayor Meadward
through you so there was a we didn't receive a delegation request over the
weekend but we did receive an email this morning noting that a person would like
to delegate or looking for a follow-up so not too sure what happened there but
if council would like to let would add Lynn Crosby to the list of other the
other two late delegate requests I think that would be appropriate. Okay thank you
clerk and that is to what item? That is to the report DGM-03-06 the
development charges. Okay all right so that delegate has been added Councillor
Nisan. Thank you through the chair your worship I'm glad that we can add that
person I'll support all the late delegations obviously however I would
just like to read 46.1 of our procedure bylaw it says request a delegate at a
committee meeting and council must be submitted to the clerk's department
prior to noon the day before a meeting if the meeting is held on a Monday
delegations must register by 12 p.m. the Friday before the meeting obviously
today is Tuesday and I recognize that we don't want our staff working on the
weekend but the procedure bylaw does not take that into account so I would
like to I would like to understand why we didn't allow these registrations and
basically there there could be people who thought they they would delegate but
weren't given the opportunity because the agenda wasn't released in a timely
fashion. Through you Mayor Meadward my apologies my understanding with the
procedure bylaw was it did revert to the Friday on a with the holiday Monday but
like the warning the wording is at the very best not clear there so I tend to
agree that and that with that wording that maybe that delegate should have
been confirmed and listed. Okay well thank you thank you for saying that and
welcome Mike it's gonna be that's an interest yeah I mean what can I say my
concern and it's a concern to ask Blake Hurley our Commissioner of Legal
Services is we're supposed to be approving a zoning bylaw today and I want
to confirm that we are not this might have to go into close I hope not but
that we're not exposing ourselves here by not having provided the correct the
agenda in a timely fashion and correct notice for delegations on our zoning
bylaw kind of a big deal so. Blake go ahead. Thank you and through the chair to
the Councillor the short answer is no we are able to proceed today with respect
to that with respect to the larger picture of the procedure bylaws as this
council knows it's we'd like to treat it as a living kind of breathing document
that makes amendments over time to improve the process and this is
certainly something that will take back so we don't find ourselves in this
situation again it's striking that balance between getting the agenda out
at a reasonable time to allow people to review it and request to delegate before
this council and on the flip side internally making sure that any
additional information that needs to be provided to council that was requested
from committee there's time to produce that information so it's it's a balance
and I think we we fell a little bit short on the on the public access side
of it but I think there's tweaks that we can make to the procedure bylaw to
improve that and that's something that will take away and and bring forth in
the future thank you. Okay Councillor Currence. Thank you very much through the
mayor so I wasn't going to ask this question until I was alerted and alarmed
by the clerk indicating that the the delegate did indicate that they've
filled in the online form but didn't receive a confirmation until an email
follow-up so how we know if there's other people who filled in the same form
and then didn't receive a confirmation and are unable to delegate today we do
as Councillor Nielsen mentioned have some very serious issues on the agenda today
that would require public engagement so complemented with the late agenda notice
and a failure for confirmation of delegation registration how we know that
we have all of the community's voice here with us today.
Through you madam chair we could do a back-end check of the website
that would take we probably require another recess to do that but I think
maybe five minutes but at through that that would be the only way to truly know
all right let's take five minutes to do a double check on our IT to make sure
that everyone who wanted to delegate was able to delegate so we will come back at
955 thanks.
you
all right folks we're back and I'll turn it to the clerk go ahead.
Thank you mayor Meadward and thank you to members of council and the public for
bearing with us what we did this confirming that there are we we did not
receive a request through Lynn Crosby the last one received was from David
Barker who is on the list and I'm satisfied that there are no other
delegates wishing to delegate today. Okay Councillor Stolti. I just want to
comment and express my concern comments made by our legal commissioner thank
you which were I understand totally appropriate but just the the very
comment to say we fell short on the public access side of it that is the
truth here and it makes me feel entirely uncomfortable that we're moving forward
not having I mean the ability to fundamental aspect of democracy is to
notify the public in an appropriate manner to allow them the opportunity to
create a delegation and come forward so I would have felt much more comfortable
if on Friday knowing that we had a late agenda that we had posted a notice online
to say that the you know the deadline to register was extended that I know
that we're going to do that moving forward but that doesn't change the
fact of what has happened for this meeting today I just want to register
that I'm very uncomfortable moving forward I think we're pushing things
through on a very heavy agenda making big big decisions potentially today
without having had the opportunity for everyone who wanted to delegate to be
able to do so so I just wanted to register that. Councillor Nisan. I agree
with Councillor Stolti even if this was a light agenda like we had in previous
months I wouldn't be supporting this I'm not sure we should even be going ahead
frankly I'm not sure how to deal with it but here we are it doesn't meet our
own standards I understand that the procedure bylaws a tweak is a living
document but it's really an amendable set of rules that we live by here so in
terms of engagement not following our procedure bylaws problematic it's not
tweaking it's that's not a tweaking matter in my in my opinion and we don't
know if there are other delegates who would have wanted to delegate today my
question for for staff is why didn't the agenda come out in a reasonable time on
Friday what was the hold-up that forced the agenda to come after any reasonable
time what was staff doing thank you. I don't know if that was for Kurt or for
you but go ahead. Through you Mayor council will recall at committee
last week there were several requests for additional information that we were
compiling we wanted to make sure that we were compiling that information and
responding to the nature of requests in a comprehensive manner I believe is part
of packaging that information it took a little bit longer that delayed the
release of the agenda and that was you know the circumstance in this case I
think there are lessons to be learned I think the the statement around the fact
that we do need to build in these circumstances and address them in future
updates to the procedural bylaw and always be erring on the side of being
more open transparent and inclusive to public perspective is fundamental and
that's something that we don't take lightly we will take away. Thank you.
Second question. Sorry Blake had his hand up do you want to hear from Blake first?
Okay go ahead Blake. Thank you Mayor and through the through the chair to the
councillor I also just want to make sure that council is aware that the
procedure bylaw requires that delegates request to delegate must be submitted to
the clerk's event prior to 12 p.m. one business day before a meeting so the
fact that we were late on the in the day on Friday and providing the agenda was
that in of itself was not the issue the issue was that the Monday was the
holiday and we have a couple of times I think over the last number of years ran
into this problem where council followed on a Tuesday after a holiday Monday and
that's where we find ourselves in an issue in providing that access and I
mentioned previously there's opportunity to address that both when we look at
setting the meeting calendar in advance for a following year and making any
adjustment to the procedure bylaw to address those circumstances where we
have a Tuesday council meeting following a holiday Monday so in the normal course
there would have been an opportunity to provide those requests for delegations
even with the later the later release of the agenda on Friday we have and it's
been this council's practice to allow late delegation so there is that
opportunity I think that's how we've operated here but bringing it back to
the point of is there a concern from a municipal municipal act perspective in
terms of councils decisions here are they invalidated in some manner because
we haven't followed our procedure bylaw to the letter the answer to that is no
council can move forward today with its items on the agenda without being
concerned that there's a municipal act issue well I just want to apologize
because I was looking at the procedure bylaw through Google search I don't know
if you guys realize how hard it is to pull up our procedure bylaw but I pulled
it up through through Google appeared to be the latest version so I do
apologize for that one business day before there's nothing wrong with our
procedure bylaw in that regard actually the problem is the agenda didn't come
out in a timely manner and so my second question is was it or was it not the
strong mayoral direction that came out we were notified Thursday morning the
day before or the day isn't that the day of the agenda was that not the holdup
not the other elements which were very short reports relatively speaking
through the mayor through the chair to the counselor the strong mayor direction
along with a another further request for information to committee to be provided
before council those items took us later into Friday then we'd hoped for again
we're trying to strike that balance of getting the best information before
council to council with providing that opportunity for the agenda to be
advanced as as early as possible so that that's the reason for the delay okay
well your worship I just want to clarify that when I requested more information
on the financials Act committee which was not necessarily supported it but I
made a request for it that were you commenting now sorry cancer are you
commenting on the motion comment yeah go ahead time you all right thanks sorry
about that yeah we're even between both we're just trying to keep track go ahead
yeah I just want to I just want to comment on what was stated there because
I asked if there could be any more information provided before council and
I want to just be clear that I understood that not everything could be
provided in that time frame and I just wanted anything that could be provided I
certainly was not implying that that report should be held up and caused the
mess that we're in right now and I'm quite confident that that report could
have been concluded if we hadn't gotten this strong mayor direction and have
many pages of information I don't know how staff put together what they did put
together that was phenomenal by the CFO's team to do anything and there are
in that information but procedurally I believe that's that's what caused us to
be in this situation and I I think we're in a real muck now thank you there's
there's no demonstrating thank you very much we try to make sure that we respect
everything everyone has to say whether you agree or disagree so I'd ask you not
to do that again I saw your hand councillor Sherman I don't know if you
wanted to speak okay I I wanted to jump in for a question a first-time question
then I'll come to you councillor Kearns so I'm just wondering in light of the
concerns that have been expressed if council can stand down this entire
meeting and reconvene a special council meeting and what notice would be
required to do so and then I will look to a mover and seconder to make that
happen councillor Sherman is willing to move I'm sure there will be a seconder
councillor bentovania thank you I guess that's over to you Blake how much notice
do we need to recon to convene a special to deal with everything except I would
suggest the recognition of the teacher who is here I think we can deal with
that and then every other item there's there's quite a few that that folks are
interested in would go to a special council meeting to be convened go ahead
thank you mayor it so I see the clerk is looking up the details on that right now
I would note that we are we have convened this meeting this this council
meeting is is before you there's an agenda that's before you and you've
already proceeded with some of some of the items on that agenda the procedural
in nature so we're already there if we're going to adjourn this meeting and
not take a look at the other items on the agenda I think if I feel more
comfortable if we take a look at that we adjourn once again I understand the that
is uncomfortable and a bit not very smooth but I think it's important for
council if they're wishing to consider this that has the best information
before them okay let's take five minutes is it will that be enough time to
consider the the the request to potentially adjourn the balance of the
meeting thank you I'd suggest ten is appropriate in this instance okay before
we do a councillor Stolti has a point of order go ahead thank you I'm certainly
was just about myself to put this question before our clerk or our legal
department my concern is that we do have a couple of delegates who made the
effort to come in in person today so what I'd like to know is an advanced
version of this question which is can we go so far down in our agenda as to make
sure we honor the fact that we have delegates who did come forward today
because I don't want to put them out and have them have to come back again maybe
they can't come back again on the date that we reschedule for so can we hear
the delegates who've come forward today and then adjourn the meeting so that
those who wish to delegate and we can get proper information and proper
engagement from everyone thank you counselor and through the chair that's
something we'll look at over the break and as I say this may be as simple as
deferring items to a special council meeting deferring the items that
council wishes to defer to a special council meeting proceeding with the
parts of the agenda that they they do wish to proceed with but we'll take a
look at that and come back with that advice okay great we'll take ten minutes
and sorry okay go ahead Councillor current thank you very much so with my
point of order I do want to ask if there's an option to allow the delegates
to speak today if they wish or if they can defer their delegations and the
second point of order would be I'd like a correction to the procedure bylaw
where clapping is in fact allowed in chambers it's a gap in our current
procedure bylaw and it's fully allowed so I just like that correction to be
made please. Councillor Sharma go ahead. Thank you very much I just want to make
the comment that we do have an agenda it's a legal meeting we have people who
shown up here to attend this meeting and they'd really like to see the work
getting done today I appreciate we have this procedural matter but there's real
work to be done by this council and and if we could get through that that would
be really handy but I'll leave it to staff to figure it out thank you okay we
will take ten minute recess and reconvene to see where we're going for
the rest of today so we will be back at 10 17 folks
you
all right folks we're back before I give the lay of the land I'll turn it to
Councillor Stolti for a question go ahead thank you mayor so my question is to
likely our city clerk sorry Mike I know you're being tested today and you know
what my my apology to you is genuine and my apologies to the rest of the staff as
well I know that the reason the reasons for the late agenda that is resulting in
us having late registered delegates and possibly some others who would like to
delegate is partially due to staff needing to get reports out and
information back to us that we saw it and I just want to apologize to staff to
say that is really unfortunate and puts you in a really difficult position to
give us what we are asking for but then it results in us having issue with the
fact that the agenda was late so what I'd like to now comment on is to say
that I'll be putting forward and I will reiterate this in a notice of motion I
did have the opportunity to have a conversation with some of the clerk
staff during the break to say is there anything with them so the sorry this is
my question to you Mike is there anything within the municipal act or a
procedure bylaw that prevents us from bringing motion forward to change our
calendar because up until two years ago we had a buffer week between committee
and council and that we didn't run into this so is there anything that prevents
us from reorganizing to give staff the time to give us what we're asking for to
give time for agendas to come out in a timely manner and for residents to be
able to read it register to delegate and avoid this come the future.
Through you Mayor Meadward nothing in this block that I'd be aware of and I
don't believe there's anything in procedure bylaws it's standard for
council to amend a committee a calendar committee and council calendar throughout
the year. Okay thank you so just as a heads up to my fellow colleagues I'll be
putting forward a notice of motion that I will be looking to do that because
this is this is absurd on so many levels that we're pushing things through we're
not giving people the opportunity to read we're not giving the opportunity
to delegate we're putting staff in a very difficult position if none of that
is necessary then I think we need to fix it.
Councillor Currance. So since I have the ability to comment I would just like to
bring everyone's mind to a reminder that when the procedure bylaw amendments
came forward I flagged that there were major deficits and it wasn't viewed as a
complete document for these reasons one was demonstrations two was holiday
Mondays and there was a number of other ones including speaking time and there
were gaps that were unclear also including how the code of conduct is
embedded within the bylaw which it should be a standalone policy and I was
told that that was very insulting to staff and that I shouldn't be making
comments like that and criticizing staff for delivering an incomplete document
were my exact words we've now had two now mode notices of motion about
amendments on the fly to the procedure bylaw not a complete review of the
procedure bylaw which is overdue for its complete review as are many policies
which we didn't get a date from the acting CAO on the committee of when
those policies would be brought in or prioritized so we're really doing some
poor work on the floor here by piecemealing amendments to the bylaw when
it needs to be looked at as a whole we just heard one issue which was
demonstration clapping which is allowed in chambers because of that gap and so
my my idea is maybe we could go back and look at the procedure bylaw in whole so
that we don't find ourselves winding up in such an embarrassing situation as we
are today and that we don't piecemeal individual little pieces of the
procedure bylaw by amendment by amendment because let's not forget every
time we amend a bylaw it's subject to appeal so now we're gonna be in a
never-ending cycle of appeals so that's my comment and I also need to know
if we're going to be my second question is can you please make sure we have
clarity on how we're treating the delegates today procedurally thank you
counselor I don't see any other questions so I will now answer that
question by way of bringing us back to where how we're going to proceed today
so the motion on the floor which we will need to vote on is to allow the late
registered delegates to speak our next item is approval of the agenda so during
approval of the agenda council has the ability to take out all some of the
items that we are going to deal with and refer them to a special council meeting
to be called by the mayor in accordance with the rules of the procedure which at
this point the earliest we could do that would be next week or it could be tucked
but we don't need to land a date so when we get to that once we vote on this and
when we get to approval of the agenda we do have a motion from counselor
Sharman and bentovania to refer any items council wishes to a future meeting
and so we can go through item by item there may be several there may only be
one but that will be that will be our opportunity to to deal with that and see
what we want to deal with today so I'll turn it over to the city solicitor go
ahead Blake thank you chair and I just wanted to through you in response to
counselor current question I think as we consider this motion to weigh the rules
procedure she had a question with respect to delegates so a red delegate
who is registered to speak today can speak today even if the item that
they're looking to speak to is deferred to a future meeting so their their
comments would still be heard there if the delegate decides that you know what
I'd rather speak at the meeting this item is going to be called at they can
register to delegate at a special council meeting in the normal course I
hope that answers your question okay all right I don't see any other hands on the
board so I will simply say that I am always appreciative of council our track
record has been to always hear from anyone who wished to speak I can't
think of a time that we didn't allow people to speak for whatever reason they
couldn't register or they they were late so I do really appreciate that I will
also note that some folks that who were given an opportunity to speak said they
would rather simply submit their information in writing that is also an
option we did get a number of pieces of correspondence so really this is for
residents to be able to engage sorry this is comment now on the on the late
registration so time it thank you clerk so there's really many different ways
that residents have to share their views with us you don't have to come to a
the way that you wish to to give your information but you certainly can and we
have had a number of individuals submit information in writing I will say with
respect to the the late agenda and the information provided that my initial
thinking before issuing the strong mayor's powers was simply to ask the
questions on the floor of council I as is my normal practice I give staff a
heads up that the questions are coming so that they can be prepared and due to
the nature of the questions felt that that was it was important to issue a
mayor's direction in full transparency so that that could be posted the answers
could be available to everyone in advance rather than doing the questions
on the floor so and as noted it was all the questions of committee not just that
that led to where we are today so certainly we can we can deal with with
all of that today and and we will. Councillor Nison go ahead. Thank you
worship I will not allow a strong mayoral direction giving two days notice
to be considered a matter of transparency and giving staff time if
this was really about giving staff time then this item would be deferred to a
future council meeting that was voted against that committee but that's
exactly what needs to happen that's why the despite all of this being caused by
a last-minute mayoral direction that is mandatory to respond to that's how we
got here and as a result the staff did their best but they couldn't even
provide complete information how did we go from a committee meeting where I was
being told that this was no big deal and that that the CFO had already given us
what he could give us according to members of committee to to multiple
pages of questions and expecting a response within 24 hours that's not
even fair to staff never mind to the public so that's why this item frankly
going to special counsels a start but there are there are legal questions that
are unanswered in that report there are financing questions that are unanswered
in that report so I'm not going to sit here and be told that this is this was a
good thing that occurred far from far from it that's why we've got all these
people many of whom are being paid right now to be here to deal with this on a
matter that frankly shouldn't even be here because we couldn't even get
delegates in time so I'm sorry but this is not right thank you
councillor our bylaw does not allow disruption so I would ask you not to
disrupt the the speaking and I'll go to councillor bentovania next go ahead
point of order go ahead thank you I'm not aware of any ban on on that in our
procedure bylaw could you point to the section please
they're here to respond to us I'm not saying that clapping is ideal but at
least they're getting there they're getting their say in some fashion
through you mayor Mead Ward the bylaw the procedure bylaw doesn't allow
unreasonable or offensive conduct and means conduct over statements that can
be considered disruptive that's the the best I can do without a recess to to
determine further all right councillor bentovania go ahead thank you mayor I've
been listening pretty intently here I'd like to rewind a little bit here we
started talking about procedure bylaws and so on and we've talked about the
cart before the horse here this is all here we're here discussing this because
we're saying that mayor's powers did what they did and I understand that I
personally commend the mayor for asking those questions the timing was maybe
not the right timing but they were very very important questions our meeting
was on Monday we have been discussing this topic for six months I sit and
listen to the P2P committee meetings and we've been discussing it there for
quite a while frankly and I gotta be careful what I say here when I read the
responses to the mayor's questions I was upset I was upset because that should
have been brought forward within that six-month period of our discussions and
I'm just saying that's just me the questions the answers were valid and they
made a lot of sense we were going to make a decision today based on information
that we didn't know that we got answers for which for me is very important so
I'll leave it at that and because of that now we again I'm going back and we
start talking about procedural bylaw we wouldn't be having this discussion
whatsoever if we were getting information along the way whether it be
legal operational or planning and anything be hunky-dory thank you all
right speaking to the late registered delegates
councillor current for a second time go ahead thank you I just wanted to widen
the scope a little bit on the conversation that we're having today
about late notice and it is not just the the matter of the development charges so
I have a number of email communications and an in-person delegation who only
received a notice regarding heritage designation on February 11th and were
given until February 6th at committee to respond you can obviously know that
those dates don't line up and maybe some of them are here today or some of them
have written we're not sure the root cause of that delay in notice but this
is another item that I was going to be intending to seek a deferral on to
another committee cycle because of the late notice for the community to
understand what the city is doing and what the impact is on their property or
on the policy so we're we're really in a bad spot today and that's going to be
one of the items that I was either asking for a referral to another cycle
asking for a root cause in corrective action or understanding more about what
we're doing to appropriately notify the community so they can appropriately
delegate and understand the matters before committee so the notice of
non-designation for new designation heritage properties was going to be
another item so I just wanted people to understand this whole delay is not
scoped to one item this is starting to become a behavioral trend that needs to
be addressed so I just wanted to add that clarity to the reason why we're
having such a difficult start to this morning okay thank you I am NOT seeing
any more hands on the board so we will vote on the item to allow the late
register delegates to speak and then give the delegates the option to speak
or not as they wish so we will turn to the clerk for the recorded vote on that
through you Mary B. Dwyer I just want to just mention that is amended this is
considering all three names including Lynn Crosby yeah so just for clarity
David Barker regarding the item on development charges Senate Shannon
Gillies regarding the heritage item and Lynn Crosby regarding the development
charges item so three delegates in total who will be given the choice to delegate
yes okay like go ahead counselor Galbraith support
Councillor Kearns support Councillor Nielsen support Councillor Stolti support
Councillor Sharman support Councillor Bentavenia support and Mayor Meadward
support that's seven in favour and that does carry okay before we hear from the
delegates we still have to deal with our agenda so this is the option where we
can go through item by item to see if there are items that council wishes to
refer to a separate council meeting to be called by the mayor in accordance
with the procedure bylaws so I would suggest that we go to the recommendations
from standing committee and we can see which ones we want to move out
councillor Stolti go ahead I'd like to put a motion on the floor in regards to
our agenda moving forward for us to now go through the agenda item by item we're
presupposing and assuming what members of the public would have wanted to
delegate on had they received information in a timely manner and had
they understood that the delegation opportunity to register for a late
delegation had been extended so I want to propose that we move the whole agenda
to a later date okay we can so does that include the recognitions and
achievements the ceremonial items are just the business when we get to the
recommendations which is item 13 just the business it was I wanted to have
this put on the floor before we start going through it item by item okay so
now is the time because we have we're in the approval of the agenda so we are
dealing with what we're going to deal with today so so fair enough speaking to
the approval of the agenda council currents I thank you I'll seek some
procedural guidance I'm in the same thought I only want to hear from
delegates today and the special presentation and I'd like to see
everything else moved solicitor go ahead thank you mayor and chair I leave
that decision for council to make the only thing that I would raise is that
there are a number of confidential items on the agenda today including a number
that were instructions are sought I would recommend that we proceed forward
with getting that approved by council today as a number of those instructions
are time-sensitive in terms of the counselors concern with respect to
public delegations obviously the members of the public would not be delegating on
those confidential matters in any event so I don't think the concern impacts
those items okay thank you councillor Nissan thank you worship no I have no
concern about the closed session being dealt with today as public engagement is
limited through the municipal act on that matter so I have no issue with that
I would say that I'm not interested also in going like item by item I think we
push it all just in case because the there's been a real process problem
here that can only be resolved that way finally I'll just give you a heads up
your worship I do not have any gaps in my calendar for the next two weeks I'm
representing Halton region at an FCM board meeting the exception to that is
the actual timing of our committees committee of the whole which is only two
weeks away so literally less than two weeks away so I would ask that we deal
with the timing of this here in public with everyone here because the rule of
procedure says that if you have a quorum you can go ahead with a meeting and that
could lead to a distortion of our electoral process by only having four
people this has happened to me on several occasions due to my obligations
with FCM where a special council meeting was called for a time where I'm not
available and I've raised those concerns with the office of the clerk so I want
to get ahead of that now and we all have committee of the whole on the Monday in
our calendar if committee of the whole items in March get pushed to that to
council in March that's perfectly acceptable and with plenty of precedence
so that will be my motion at the correct time your worship is that we move
everything to the second of March thank you thank you we're just go ahead
councillor Sherman well thank you very much and I think there were consent
items that we all approved as well and I'm not too bothered by passing those I
think there is work that we can do realistically today and I think that we
should I will not be supporting and move a movement to defer the entire meeting
I I'm happy to see a few removed thank you okay council Galbraith I will also
not be supporting a full agenda move I think we're all here today and there's
several items that we can deal with so I'd prefer to deal with as many as we
can today and then move the one or two items that are more time-sensitive to a
future meeting within the next couple of weeks thank you okay so we do need to
get a motion on the floor relative to the agenda and there may be additional
modifications so councillor Stolti and councillor Nissan I will leave it to you
to move and second something so you want the entire business moved councillor
Stolti and perhaps we can get that language up on the screen and councillor
Nissan wanted it moved to the previously scheduled council meeting date which is
March 2nd I believe but we'll get that clarified and we'll get the language up
on the board have I understood your intent yes I agree with the March 2nd
date and I would like to propose that we move the entire agenda following
proclamations recognition and achievements and the opportunity for
our registered and late registered delegates to be able to delegate should
they choose to delegate today and what's on the board is the dealing with the
confidential items yes and the confidential items as well you're okay
with that okay and we'll need future special counsel to be changed to the
date of committee as requested by councillor Nissan so we'll put that in
Debbie and then open the floor if there are additional changes that committee
wishes to put with respect to that which could include the consent items or other
items that count that council wishes to deal with today
councillor Nissan go ahead I'll just wait for this to be up on the board I
just want to second just as a point of order I think the title is the old
title at this point so and I just want to confirm that only a majority is
required versus two-thirds I'm actually not a hundred percent sure but I think
that's the case three mayor made word yes just a majority to defer items okay so
that is the that's the motion on the floor does anyone wish to speak to the
motion any changes to the motion okay going to the clerk for the vote to go
ahead because councillors Stolti sorry just was rereading I was
mistaken the February 17th okay thank you
councillor Nissan thank you I'll just make a quick comment before the vote I
want to thank councillor Stolti for your support on this and to my colleagues who
might be on the fence or otherwise I think this fixes it I think that you know
if it's an issue that you feel passionately about you would want to hear
from the public on it as well that's how I would approach it anyways speaking for
myself I feel passionately about several items on the agenda here and one in
particular and I would not want the public to be cut out of the process
which is what we are nearly about to do so with that I would just ask for your
support thank you councillor Stolti yeah I just want to follow that up just by
commenting that I certainly take what staff have gratefully brought to our
attention that there are some time-sensitive matters in our
confidential agenda that we should go through with today the rest of the
agenda is not time-sensitive whether it wakes a couple of weeks in order for
proper due diligence and proper procedure bylaw and proper engagement of
the public to happen I think that's the right thing to do and I think pushing
things forward unnecessarily today is just reckless
councillor currents I just want to thank everyone for their I mean ability to to
move this this is the right thing to do we're in the midst of doing our
engagement charter again and this is a great example of how we take the
priority of having the community's voice at the table here in this horseshoe
this is the right thing to do it might be uncomfortable but sometimes doing
what's right is uncomfortable I look forward to more engagement on the very
very serious and very very expensive matters that are in this agenda as well
as making sure that we we get things right the first time which I mentioned a
deferral about like failure for notice we don't know why yet around a very
serious heritage matter as well so I'm looking forward to having this supported
and you know I'm hoping that within this there is a communications plan to let
people know about some of what's going on and how this has been deferred so I
certainly want to hear from the delegates I don't actually know if
that's procedurally okay but I'll go with your word I want to hear from the
delegates today we want to do the special ceremony but I have no interest
in going piecemeal item by item of what is in and what is out that is not
respecting the community voice or our commitment to engagement.
I want to start off by thanking the mayor for the for the Strong Mayor Power
document that was gone that actually stimulated a significant piece of
work that should have been done months ago I agree with Council Bintervenia
I do agree that it was tight coming in on the timeline and that we're ending up
in a position a day later where we're making adjustments so I'm
completely in support of deferring that matter it needs to have the light of day
for the members of public to see it and comment on it and I and I and sincerely
the motion that we put forward to change the procedural bylaw to accommodate
the the degree of discipline that two of my colleagues have been asking for
around Strong Mayor's Powers all along is now dealt with and you did that that
Strong Mayor Power motion in that context so kudos to you and I strongly
believe that there are items in here that should be dealt with today they're
not contentious you know I will never support a heritage designation, forced
designation so I absolutely agree that if we need to do that deferral I'm okay
with that as well as the DC the DC charges and the zoning bylaw there with
the outside as far as I'm concerned can be done thank you.
Councilor Niesma for a second time.
Yes exactly thank you chair.
Since it's been brought up more than once and this might be the last chance to
address this there I'm hearing appreciation for the new information and
I'm hearing an implication which others are welcome to say that's not the case
but let's just say I want to be really clear that this is not something that
staff have failed to give us in the past six months or that you wish you had
gotten sooner with this is the board of directors of the city if we wanted it we
need to ask for it and the reason why it didn't come sooner is because frankly it
was outside of the realm of thought that we would be asking for a two-year DC
bylaw elimination without being made whole I mean if you go back to last fall
the the mayor's motion was on the condition of being made whole so why
would they produce a long report on the financial implications when
everything that they knew up until now until the committee was that we would be
getting made whole remind everyone that that amendment from the mayor although
thankfully came to council members early was not given to the public early to my
knowledge so that we can't expect staff to read our minds this is our job we're
the board of directors so I do not I would not agree with any implication if
there was any implication which I think there was that this was something that
staff should have done sooner that's on us this is a change it's a very last
minute change worth the with risk and also with respect to being so pleased
about getting this information then you know for the for those who voted against
the two-month deferral why did you vote against the two-month deferral in
committee then if you wanted that information because frankly you do not
have complete information right now from the CFO and their team there are clear
gaps where they said they did not have enough time to provide that information
so if you really want the information you should be supporting a two-month
deferral not a too weak deferral to a special counsel if not then there's
something else at play you know I'll retract that what I want to say is that
there is obviously more going on than a question of deferrals and we need this
time for the for the public to be involved there are two things that are
wrong with strong mayor powers number one it's not democratic and number two it
messes up procedure and this is about the latter procedure is getting messed
up because unlike before strong mayor powers decree can be made at the last
minute that forces staff to do things that they cannot reasonably be expected
to do and that's exactly what happened here thank you
council Stolti for a second time go ahead thank you I want to thank
councillor Nisan for his comments and I want to add to them to actually it's a
question to staff when the conversation was had last week when amendments were
put on the floor as far as requesting further time as councillor Nisans
brought up in order to get more information about how this might impact
us in many different ways and impact the public and impact the budget and all
sorts different things would you have preferred for the mayor to have come
forward today with an amendment to ask for that time the valid amount of time
in order to get this information to you or did you would you prefer the way it
was approached as far as pressing the strong mayor powers to request to
request two days to get that information to us Steven I think that's over to you
or the CFO Craig was a direction to the two of you to answer questions go ahead
thank you through the mayor thanks for the question I mean I think at the end
of the day we are we are staff are at the mercy of council so we do our best
to provide what we think is appropriate information so well yes it's always good
to have more time and but we'll do our best to answer questions as they come up
as we're directed to okay so to follow up on that I appreciate that was a
difficult question that I was asking you and I just want to concur with
councillor Nissan that if this council and members of council and the mayor
had wanted more information there was opportunities given last Tuesday to
create that opportunity in a manner that was more respectful of staff and more
respectful of the public so I completely disagree with the comment about the
strong mayor powers being used in a way that was helpful I think it was
disrespectful councillor bentovania go ahead and my last comment on this will
be we talk about the impact and again we can all cherry-pick what we want to talk
about we sit around this horseshoe table and we talk about things and there
are many many items that we discuss in terms of recommendations that we get
from staff from the experts in the field we are not and I'll focus on this
because I'm going to cherry-pick for the first time we are not legal people there
was some legal information that we received that perhaps in our discussions
in the past maybe that comment that discussion should have come up again I'm
not throwing anyone under the bus here but I want to protect and respect what's
going on around this table and had we had that information two months ago three
months ago I may have had a different discussion on that specific topic
because that information could have been detrimental in a decision-making and I
work with trust and information and questions I may not necessarily ask but
we need to know we need to know that information thank you
Councillor Currens for a second time thanks very much so imagine my shock when
after being unwell for committee of the whole I come back and I see that we've
now moved from what the original motion was which was this is around the
development charges which was that the reduction was tied to some degree of
achieving policy goals like purpose-built rental market affordability
the reduction was conditional on being made whole and that the reduction would
only apply to projects with a certain definition of a start or completion and
then I find out to my discovery in response to the strong mayor's request
which staff responded three times due to limited time staff was unable to that is
stated three times in the supplementary report that it's a hundred percent it's
for everything including market rate including luxury condos and that it's
basically going to be pretty much immediate and we won't know the effects
until about 2027 and that we don't have enough in our capital reserves or tax
stabilization reserve and that we only make about a million dollars in our
surplus end of year which is not enough to cover the numbers that are
contemplated which is between six and forty seven million dollars so I was
shocked to find out that that's the trajectory that this conversation went
on and if I'm shocked I have to believe the community is shocked or they just
actually have no idea so I never saw a media release I never saw a
communication out to the public on such a huge amount when we talked about
putting more money into the 2% infrastructure on top of your normal
taxes we put 2% on top to fund infrastructure if we put another 0.5
that's only $700,000 and we're talking about the magnitude of six million to
forty something million this is insane and to have this come forward on the
Friday of a long weekend where even one of the councillors just by missing one
day which is rare is completely blindsided I don't commend the strong
mayor's piece because I don't think that the entire council was solicited to say
are there any outstanding questions you have that you would like included in a
strong mayor's directive to force staff over a long weekend to respond and
leading up to a long weekend to respond to I think it was a poor use of the
powers which I've objected to since day one and to say that this is commendable
it is not it is very dangerous to be commanding our staff to do something
outside of the purview of the CAO this bypassed the top of the organization and
went straight to staff that is not a healthy workplace and I don't commend
this one bit this is information that we should have had ought to have had and
when the conversation changed so abruptly from what was first brought
forward in October even West End homebuilders for their original
communications in September asked for a reduction not a hundred percent removal
so that is a huge shift I don't I don't I'm just flabbergasted we're here
councilor Sherman go ahead well thank you very much and I think the council
has just completely stated the concerns I would have and why I wish that matter
to be deferred so that solves that problem the with respect to the numbers
I thought I heard staff agree that the initial numbers that were in the in the
original report that went to cow that there was no 40 million dollars there's
not that range of numbers involved and that fact they agreed with the numbers
we were hearing from the from the federal government in terms of what
numbers should be expected it was dramatically less than any of those
large numbers furthermore the there is the cost associated the process in these
applications is fully covered by the amount of work that our staff presently
have on this table what we're talking about is actually an adjustment of
reserves rather than lost revenue per se and this will all be accommodated in
the short term I put I totally agree that what has occurred since committee
was was like sausage making it caused us to ask important questions and I
certainly agree that with the with the idea that we move our council to a two
week gap so that we don't have to deal with nonsense again we need time in
between we need to have the opportunity to ask questions and get them answered
and we need to have the the public available to participate in the process
anyway I'm I'm thinking that we should take the vote mayor
councillor Nissan you've spoken twice do you have a question go ahead
very direct question to our staff based on your updated report to our CFO do you
stand by your figures of a 16 to 42 million dollar estimate as provided by
yourself in every report that I've seen so far sorry I'm just I'm just gonna
pause for a moment we are straying a wee bit away from what we're getting into a
bit of discussion of the item I'm okay to proceed I understand there's concerns
but we're really only talking about a deferral of items to another meeting now
and I know a lot of things have been said that have kind of brought additional
items in I'm just wondering if you can hold that question till we actually deal
with the item well I think there's a there's a problem here which is that a
council member has made assumptions about a staff position that I haven't
seen before so I would really appreciate if we could just clear that up very
briefly and get back right on thank you
so you provided additional numbers in the memo do you want to speak to that
CFO through through the mayor thanks for the question I mean I think it's
important to recall that this is the second report there was a report that we
did in October and the information that we provided the range it's a team effort
it's the data was built on what's in the pipe what we're aware of but it's a big
range and I think if anything it highlights how difficult it is year to
forecast what's going to get built and what isn't going to get built and I
think to the best of our ability that was our intent to convey through both
staff reports so yes I do stand behind the range that we provide
councillor Stulte you've spoken twice do you have a question I do and it's in
relation to the commentary that we were on right now about the finances with the
comment that councillor Sherman brought up about it not necessarily in his
belief being revenue that's necessary to be brought through taxes but use the
reserve funds if we were to use reserve funds is there not an opportunity cost
of those reserves being available for other important business of the city
no we're straying a bit do you feel it's best to deal with this when we get to
the item or would you like to answer it now it's up to you well if you don't
mind I'll answer it now just because it's things moving along so at the end
of the day if there are no other revenue sources available to the city and we do
have to replenish those DC reserves there will be some impacts you're
moving from one reserve to another so it will cause us to have less funding for
some other projects and over time that you know the extent of the exemption
would would dictate what that impact would overall look like thank you all
right any other speakers or questions on the deferral okay I will take an
opportunity to say to make a few comments so it is not uncommon just so
folks are aware it is not uncommon for members of committee or council to have
additional questions of staff in between or before meetings or after they see
reports and so that that is not uncommon when the nature of those
questions are determined by staff to be substantial they will advise whether
they wish that to be put in a staff direction if there's time at a
committee meeting or in my case a mayor's decision and so the the
questions were really related to what were your assumptions before you put the
report assuming those assumptions were there I was just asking stuff to show
the work and some additional questions and I will say that for me the most
important thing is ensuring that all of council has the information that it
needs to make good decisions that is the only and singular motivation for me in
asking staff and in response to staff saying because of the nature of the
questions it would be best to put it in a mayor's direction staff also outlined
who it would be directed to the specific staff that are being asked to answer
that is why it was phrased that way so we do work together staff and council
to make sure that all of the questions that council might have that would be
material to decision-making that they are asked and that that information is
provided so I'm glad for at least some of council that that information was
helpful certainly it was eye-opening for me and I will continue to serve council
and the community to the best of my ability in any way that I can to ensure
that we have the best information when we make decisions and if that's by way
of a staff mayor's direction as advised by staff I will do that because what's
most important to me is making sure that we have the information that we need to
make good decisions I also think that the nature of the discussion we're about
to have on several items is so significant that it's important to take
a little bit of time for those who have raised concerns about the time I don't
want to argue over process I think we need to focus our attention on the
actual matter at hand so I'm okay to defer I'm okay to make sure that anyone
who wishes to provide their feedback and again delegating is only one way it's
not the preferred way of everyone but by by writing we've actually had more
pieces of correspondence than we have delegation requests so in the interest
of good decision-making good information and ensuring the community can
participate I'm okay to accept the deferral okay
councillor Stolti question I do have a question of the clerk is there anything
in the procedure bylaw that precludes questions to other members of council
through you mayor Meadward nothing that I'm aware of okay my question then is to
yourself mayor in regards to the comments you just made if it was in fact
your intent to have all the material available to council members in order
to make good decisions why did you vote against the amendment last week asking
for financial considerations before this vote came forward if that was
information that your fellow council members were looking for I felt that we
had the information and you know upon reflection this is why we have two step
process we allow ourselves time between committee and council to consider all
information and I spoke to that vote at committee and I'm okay with with what we
have in front of us today I think if you know in hearing the concerns of all of
council and members of the public that it's important to take a little bit of
extra time I'm happy to do that I will say we are in a housing crisis we are in
an emergency and every day that we delay is every day that potentially a
new house isn't getting built so sorry point of order I've just asked a
question as asked an answer thank you sure so okay
Councillor currents thank you very much this is also a question to the mayor if
you knew one of your committee members was absent for illness and you were
looking to make sure that you had all the information available as your number
one priority to council not the community why would you not circulate or
precirculate the content of your strong mayor's directive to say hey team do I
have it all here thank you very much that was that's a great question and I
did actually consider that and in this case speed was of the essence I wanted
to give staff as much time as possible and to prepare the information and to
get the question so certainly in future I am most certainly happy to circulate
in advance when it's necessary to issue a direction to get more information
thank you for that so just a follow-up question so then it was to get your
information because you didn't circulate it or was it to get the information that
council wanted under a strong mayor's directive thank you I took into
consideration all of the comments that were made by members of committee at the
meeting including councillor Nissan staff chose to report that out in two
separate reports which is totally fine but that was part of the direction and
other items that were raised during the committee meeting by by members of
committee who were present
all right I'm not seeing any other questions or comments so I think it is
time for the vote on the deferral I will turn it to your clerk
Councillor Galbraith do not support Councillor Kearns support Councillor
Nissan support Councillor Stolti support Councillor Sharman do not support
Councillor Bentavania do not support and Mayor Meadward support that is four in
favour three against and that does carry okay so we will deal with the other
items the ceremonial items as well as delegation so turning now to
declarations of interest since we have moved this item I assume the
declaration is no longer necessary but I'll turn it to the clerk it is still
necessary okay declarations of interest Councillor Galbraith yeah I'd just like
to declare an interest with item 13.1 in the confidential the real estate matter
thank you okay we do have two proclamations Black History Month
February 2026 World Down Syndrome Day March 21st 2026 and a number of peer
lightings there's quite a few so hang on February 13 lit red for wear Canada
wear red Canada heart disease February 14 of course lit red for Valentine's Day
February February 15 lit yellow and gold for International Childhood Cancer
Awareness Day Feb 28 lit winter blue warm yellow and
valley blue for the coldest night of the year March 1st lit Pantone blue for
liver liver health month March 4th lit dark blue and yellow for sudden
unexplained death in childhood Awareness Month March 7 lit yellow for endometriosis
Awareness Month lit 8 sorry March 8 lit purple for International Women's Day
March 14 lit blue for World Young Rheumatic Disease Day March 16 lit lime
green for National Poison Prevention Week March 17 lit green for St. Patrick's
Day March 22nd lit blue and green for UN World Water Day excuse me March 28 lit
white for annual Burlington in memoriam day March 28 lit blue and green for
Earth Hour March 31 lit pink white and light blue for International Transgender
Day of Visibility turning now to recognitions and achievements and I'd
like to talk about the 2025 Governor-General's History Award for
Excellence in Teaching and thank you for sticking around with us on behalf of the
City of Burlington it is my pleasure to extend sincere congratulations to Heather
Howell upon receiving the Governor-General's History Award for
Excellence in Teaching Heather Howell is a teacher at MM Robinson High School in
Ward 3 Heather your leadership in guiding students to cultivate a heritage
garden using traditional methods growing the vegetables and herbs grown by
Burlington families in the late 19th century offers a powerful hands-on
connection to our local past this national award celebrates the efforts
that keep our shared history vibrant and meaningful your project truly exemplifies
that spirit wishing you all the best as you celebrate this achievement and we
want to thank you for all that you do in the community for keeping our past alive
through this wonderful project I also want to thank the Museums of Burlington
for their close collaboration on this project and I note our executive
director Kim Watson is here and thank you both for donating to the Heritage
Garden donating the Heritage Gardens harvest to the Burlington Food Bank so
we will now meet at the podium to present Heather with a certificate from
the City of Burlington and take a picture with council I also want to
invite representatives who are here to join in the celebration at Museums of
Burlington we have Miriam Martins as well and the chair and trustee from the
Halton District School Board Amy Collard so we will gather with all of
council in the center here with the proclamation for a photo thanks
folks we actually have to vote on approval of the amended agenda which we
did not do so I will turn it back to the clerk for that vote thank you Mary
Meade Ward councillor Galbraith support councillor Kerns support councillor
Nissan support councillor Stolti support councillor Sharman support
councillor Bentavania support Mary Meade Ward support seven in favor and that
does carry I have a motion to approve the council minutes from councillor
Nissan and councillor Sharman that we approve the regular council meeting
minutes of January 26 2026 all those in favor show of hands any opposed seeing
none that does carry and we now turn to delegations so our first pre-registered
delegations delegate will be Michael Collins Williams speaking to item DGM
326 options for the temporary elimination of development charges
representing the West End Home Builders Association and you have five minutes to
provide comments and there may be questions afterwards go ahead good
morning members of committee sorry members of council mayor and city staff
my name is Mike Collins Williams I'm the CEO of the West End Home Builders
Association representing over 300 member companies across Hamilton Burlington and
Rimsby I want to be very clear at the outset I'm not here to repeat anything
that was already debated at Committee of the Whole that work has been done in
fact Burlington's been deliberating development charges relief since
September through the pipeline to permit committee through full council on
October 14th through multiple staff reports through Committee of the Whole
and now here at council we've been at this for six months there's no
information gap there's no need for further study what is required now is a
decision well the city continues to review analyze examine and create
procedural delays the industry is hemorrhaging jobs tradespeople planners
engineers suppliers Burlington residents are losing their livelihoods these are
your constituents this is not theoretical this is not cyclical softness
this is a housing pipeline that is seized up completely and we debate
procedures and circles instead of actually doing anything when projects
don't move forward development charges are not collected anyway and the city
loses far more in long-term assessments economic activity and workforce stability
delay does not pursue a preserve revenue delay eliminates it council is being
asked to act in a way that is temporary targeted enabled by provincial
legislation and responsive to extraordinary market conditions I want to
explicitly state that we HBA is fully aligned with the city of Burlington's
advocacy strategy as outlined in the mayor's correspondence to Minister
Robertson and Minister Flack contained in today's meeting package we're
lockstep on three critical points first the government of Canada must fulfill
its commitments to cover 50% of municipal development charges reductions
that commitment has been made publicly what's missing is implementation
secondly that the province step up with investments in housing enabling
infrastructure the building faster fund as currently construct structured has
been underutilized because of market conditions have changed it revised BFF
framework can and should be used to support temporary DC relief where
municipalities are showing leadership third municipal action must be rewarded
not penalized Burlington should not be financially disadvantaged for doing
exactly what senior levels of government have been asking cities to do unlock
housing supply which bees already advocating this is not theoretical
advocacy I was actually at Parliament Hill last week meeting directly with
parliamentarians on housing affordability including a direct
conversation with Minister Robertson where Burlington's leadership on
development charges was explicitly raised they take notice when you
actually take action versus doing what every other municipality does which is
nothing and immediately following this meeting I'll be seeing Minister Flack at
a housing event where the same issue will again be pressed although I'm now
an hour and a half late for that we should be able continue to partner with
the city of Burlington advocating for municipal finance reform replacement
funding and coordinated action across all orders of government final point I
do appreciate the hard work that city staff is undertaken but the revenue loss
scenarios are extremely risk adverse and I understand that's your job to be risk
adverse but there is absolutely no real-world scenario where three thousand
three hundred and fifty nine units representing 42 million dollars in DC
revenue get going over the next two years that isn't even in the realm of
possibility I'll remind council our members sold for I'll repeat that please
pay attention we sold for condo units the entire year across the entire city
in 2025 the low-end estimate of 16 million was based on a three-year
average of about 8 million a year but last year was closer to 6.8 million and
economic conditions deteriorated significantly through the second half of
last year and are even worse now going into 2026 I'm pleading with this council
not to be distracted by wildly optimistic scenarios Burlington's
willingness to act decisively on development charges is already being
noticed across industry across municipalities and it's being noticed at
Queens Park and on Parliament Hill leadership like this should be in
work reinforced not stalled so I cannot express how disappointing to delays
delay is council has studied this council has debated this council has
provided multiple opportunities for consultation at multiple engagements
throughout the fall and into the winter the time to act is now this is time
sensitive jobs are being lost every single day in Burlington thank you thank
you you do have several questions councillor Stolti you're first thank you
Mike I appreciate your passion I know you and I have spoken both in council and
I do not dispute the fact that we need to try to pull levers to get the
development community back on board and be able to put houses in the ground I
don't dispute that at all my question to you is can you agree that the ideal
version is that we find a balance and do this the right way and do you believe
that the development community will still come forward and be able to put
potentially more houses and more homes into people's hands if we create
opportunities for housing that people can actually afford when you speak about
the four units that were sold last year those were market level units those were
high-end units if the if the development community were to come forward and
that's my question to you do you not see that we could achieve both we could save
jobs we could support the development community and industry as well as
provide the type of housing that Burlington future and present Burlington
residents actually need thank you for your question we'll always work willing
to work with the city on the full spectrum of housing from below market
right through I would dispute the notion that the four units are high-end these
are condo units and those are basically entry level entry level units for first
time buyers you know the below market housing is an important part of the
cows in continuum but that represents five to ten percent of what's built in
Ontario built in Burlington most young Burlington residents do not aspire to
live in government build social housing again it's an important part of the
continuum a lot of our members are working in that space but I think the
discussion today and the last six months has shifted a little bit more from what
the specific housing product is and it's really about jobs people in Burlington
are losing jobs and whether you're a carpenter an engineer working on concrete
forming whether that's a market unit or a below market unit what's important to
those families is that they have a paycheck at the end of the day and they
can continue putting food on the table okay just a point of clarity please I
appreciate that but my question was not about government built social housing my
question is about the type of housing that's in our housing strategy which is
workforce housing it goes it straddles that middle section it does not support
housing and it's not market housing it's that middle piece and there's so many
conversations that we've had over the last number of years but opportunities
like land lease like so many creative options and I know you and I have had
this conversation and what's just what I ask is would the development community
come forward and could there be the opportunity to save jobs and to create
housing if we were to gear the development charge policy towards
creating housing that the workforce housing that our community actually
needs do you with the development community come forward and partner on
that I would say yes but there is also through bill 23 there are no development
charges currently today on below market affordable housing so if the city is to
partner with the development industry to produce below market housing to partner
say with this new build Canada Homes Agency you're already there on the
development charges there are no development charges on affordable units
so the discussion today is about the broader market and when you speak about
workforce housing I certainly believe that first-time entry-level homes
provided you know one one-bedroom plus den condos that might be built around
the go station areas that is the entry-level housing for firefighters for
people that work in the police force for teachers for nurses that is the exact
type of housing that we're trying to build yes there is a component in
Burlington that might be considered luxury but that would be sort of be the
more high-end single detached homes on a 40 or 50 foot lot not those entry-level
homes that we're trying to provide that might be town homes or you know frankly
small condos okay I have another question I'll get back thank you
Councillor Nielsen thank you through the chair thank you Mike for your
delegation just trying to put myself in your shoes here so if given how
challenging the environment has been for your members it like looking at looking
at where we are and where you are have you do you continue to take in the full
memberships fees or have you provided a discount to your members our
memberships declined on account of some companies going under bit out of
business and some companies not being able to afford the membership fees
frankly our fees aren't that high but yes we've we've experienced changes
within our membership due to the current environments and we're expecting a
forward as are we are you aware that or I mean you you represent the development
industry not the construction industry but I'm sure you know your construction
industry colleagues we're gonna lose are you aware that we're gonna lose jobs if
we don't fulfill our capital program here in Burlington for construction
workers and trades to build the roads that won't be built if we provide a
subsidy to do the to the development charges that is unfunded by the
provincial federal government is that a concern or is that not part of your
mandate through the chair all jobs are important in the construction industry
and there's some back and forth in terms of the construction workers whether
they're working on public infrastructure projects or projects in our sector I
guess I have trouble with the notion of subsidy when your revenues are crashing
as it is I think mayor Stephen Del Duca and bond said it best when he said he'd
rather get you know part of something than all of nothing your DC revenues
went down in 2025 relative to the previous couple of years if you don't
do anything going forward your DC revenues in 2026 and 2027 are probably
going to be a fraction of what they were before and I'm also concerned about the
city's long-term revenues I think that there is sometimes an over emphasis or
focus on the money right in front of you that might be collected through a DC
versus the long-term property tax revenue through assessment growth an
example would be the paradigm project that Vince Molinaro built I actually
have the numbers right in front of me that the properties on Fairview Avenue
pre-development brought in eighteen thousand and nineteen thousand dollars a
year in property taxes that's about forty thousand a year post development
one point five million dollars not once that's this year next year every year
going forward there are two additional buildings under construction that'll
probably bring in another million dollars on an annual basis so so if you
were looking at the fiscal impact the long-term fiscal impact on the city is
that if you don't get the assessment growth you're going to be in trouble in
a few years thank you and I'm gonna ask a follow-up mayor because that went a
little off off my question and I'll note that the our assessment growth figures
could not be provided in time for this meeting exactly the procedure problems
that use you have so much disdain for in your delegation that's what do you think
DC revenues are for do you think that they're for us to go spend on new fresh
things or are they to help connect people into their community for new roads
do you think that we're profiting off of DC's do you think we're profiting off of
assessment growth do you think that's all like to build new city halls or is
it to actually serve the residents? I have 20 years of experience working through DC
background studies so I have a pretty good idea of what DC revenues go
through the act has been changed multiple times and the definition of
growth paying for growth has changed multiple times there have been a series
of changes recently that filter what is benefit to existing you know long-term
10-year 10-year service standards so the definition of what growth paying for
growth is is in constant flux you do have a significant reserve in the DC's
that can be tapped into on a temporary basis and the ask here is temporary
we're asking you to provide relief on a temporary basis and then go back to the
full DC's the revenue is not coming in anyway so in terms of your long-term
capital plan DC's have been part of that in the past they'll be part of that in
the future we're trying to get shovels in the ground to save jobs to deal with
the crisis right now and as I said during my delegation we want to partner
with you with other members of council and the mayor to try to get every penny
that we can out of the federal and provincial governments as I said there's
an opportunity through the building faster fund to potentially backfill
some of that potential lost revenue and I think there's opportunities from the
federal government to fulfill some of their campaign commitments to provide
housing enabling infrastructure we're there with you we want to support
Burlington getting as much money as they can and I think that by showing
leadership you're actually putting political pressure on those levels of
government to do something. Chair, way off topic here I'm sure you'll get a chance to answer more later.
That was not what the question was about. He was asking the he was answering the
question around what DC's pay for so okay. Councillor Galbraith you're next.
Thank you Mayor and thanks for being here today Mike and thanks for the delegation.
I've often been focused on the business community in Burlington and jobs with my
support for the DC reduction. You gave us some numbers last time with regards to
Hamilton job losses last year. Do you have any update on on the Burlington job
losses last year and any any sort of outlook in the future about job losses
in Burlington if we do not make this DC reduction incentive? I don't have a
specific number for you but I can say that on roughly sort of national
averages that there are 3.8 person years of employment provided for
ground-oriented housing 1.5 person years of housing provided for multi-unit
high-rise so with each decline in housing starts or if you don't get a 200
unit building that's 300 potential job losses right there and I think longer
term you need to think beyond the actual jobs on site. There are a lot of
suppliers and manufacturers in Burlington that sort of feed into that
long-term supply chain. You know the numbers are going down with the housing
starts going down and I think last week at Committee of the Whole it was a
pretty sobering discussion from CMHC in terms of the the housing start numbers
but to answer your question directly I've got numbers per housing start but
not the specific numbers for Burlington. Gotcha thank you for that. A second
question you just kind of mentioned it but I'm curious about the political
pressure if we do this. Does this improve our chances of your advocacy work at the
federal and provincial governments if we show leadership and pass a DC reduction?
Does this improve our chances in your opinion? Through the chair significantly
there's 444 municipalities in Ontario. All of you are fighting for the attention
of Minister Flack and Premier Ford and I think since 2018 when this election
this government was elected it's been pretty clearly demonstrated that they
respond to political pressure and I think that by doing something unique by
doing something bold enrich the risk is actually fairly low because the amount
of DC revenue coming in is falling off a cliff so providing a temporary
exemption is a low-risk opportunity to put yourselves at the very top of the
pile for the provincial or federal government to look at additional
dollars be it one-time grants or something special or through reform to
the building faster fund. Thanks for that answer. Councillor Bentavania. Thank you
Mayor and thank you Mike for being here. I think we all understand where you're
coming from and I think for the most part depending again how we look at this
thing we're with you. We want to partner as best as we can. This weekend we talk
about short term I learned how to bring people into a phone call so we have more
than one so I almost had a conference call with a number of people on this
subject. My question to you Mike is did you get a chance to read the
supplementary staff memo? They're all in front of me. Okay so specifically
questions seven and eight that we have not discussed in any detail as far as I
can remember for the last six months with respect to bonusing. That was a
question that was brought up internally with people I've spoken to saying how
will that affect this program in that if we limit the dollars for example if we
do a grant program or something and we run out of money that we have committed
to I guess that's something what give me some comments on that what can we do
there? Through the chair my concern with an upside limit is that may prevent the
dollars from actually completely flowing through to the consumer. Ultimately the
we have right now is the resale value of any comparable unit in Burlington is
below the actual construction cost to build and deliver just there's a gap in
the market so the only way that we are going to be able to sell new units get
those units under construction and save jobs is to reduce pricing and by
lowering the DC's or you know we're also looking at the provincial and federal
government in terms of lowering GST or PSD we need to bring those prices down
and if it's built right into the DC bylaw we can provide full consumer
disclosure on purchase and sale agreements they'll see it right there in
black and white that there's that $12,000 and change reduction and any of our
builder members can reduce their prices accordingly. If it's through a grant
program and there's an upside limit so to speak folks in the building industry
like Vince can't put it on there they can't build it into the price in in
their sales program because they don't know if they'll ultimately receive it
that creates a lot of risk for the consumer that if they're buying I don't
know a $400,000 units and there's going to be 12 or 13 thousand dollars off it's
either built into the price right up front and they know with certainty what
the price is going to be my concern is if it's through a grant program and it's
on the back end there may be an adjustment on closing and that consumer
would have to pay the pay the additional $13,000 on closing if they don't get the
grant and depending on the bank depending on their financial situation
nobody wants an extra $13,000 unexpected bill and the bank may not close them on
their mortgage if they can't come up with that money. Thank you very much
that's helpful my second question has to do with and I want to bring up the fact
that you mentioned and you know we've talked about it 100% of nothing is
nothing and last year we received from our committee meeting six point eight
million dollars in DC charges which included which I didn't realize building
permits and applications so that's the actual real DC charges is probably less
from what I was thinking about before this happened so our discussion on the
phone was simple if we don't do this and this continues to get worse the
situation who ultimately is going to pay for the services that we have because
that's a big discussion yet our three three hundred eighty million dollar
budget is going to go up next year and if we don't get DC charges which we're
not expecting because nothing's happening that pie is going to get we're
still got to pay for that pie increase so we're going to pay now or pay more
later so through the chair that's that's a great question that if the money
doesn't come in what happens so your your neighbors just down the highway in
Toronto are going through this because they put you know they've expected
multiple billions of dollars in DC revenue coming in over the next decade
to pay for a lot of TTC work expansion etc they've hit a wall in that the condo
sector in Toronto is completely dead and they've come to the realization that
there are hundreds of millions of dollars that are never ever going to
show up as as the crisis worsens buildings get cancelled etc so the City
of Toronto right now is going through an exercise where there are potentially
going to be massive property tax increases to backfill the loss of the
DC revenue long-term capital projects are getting cancelled long-term capital
projects are getting delayed putting out a decade further and they're begging the
province and the federal government to provide relief because Toronto put too
many too many eggs in the DC basket and the condo market does not exist so on a
smaller scale something similar could happen here where your options are to
move it to the property taxes or some of those long-term capital projects won't
happen thank you for that and I know the residents are listening thank you
councillor Sharman thanks for being here like I'm just reflecting on the
presentation that we got from Anthony Pasarelli from Canada mortgage and
housing corporation at pipeline to permit and his comment their their
projection is that the high for 2026 in Burlington is 500 new and below is 300
do you think those numbers are in the right ballpark or are they still too high
or what they're likely in through the chair they're likely in the ballpark but
you have to remember that the CMHC numbers are for housing starts are based
on foundations being poured so a number of those buildings are actually already
have building permits pulled and are already under construction and are
excavating so CMHC might have a more direct line of sight on that specific
specific figure which is a little different than what the city might be
looking at in terms of future permits so they're they're probably in the
ballpark there and I believe a hundred of those units in each of those figures
was for 80 use so in terms of the more traditional housing starts be it
singles townhomes and larger buildings etc it would have been 400 rather than
500 thank you the ARR AR use were in addition to that okay I just picked the
residential but the question I have if I might follow up if you take out the ones
that CMHC would have seen anyway because they were in process then is there a
further increment on top of those that that we you would expect that would get
us into the kind of scale of the numbers that we were seeing being projected in
our you know years old assessments through the chair that's why I'm
frankly a little confused when I see three thousand three hundred and fifty
nine units in the staff report when CMHC which has a pretty good line of sight on
market conditions and what may happen are at a fraction of that you know
market conditions can change things could improve but if they improve it
would be incremental not suddenly everything in the world changes and you
know we're back to the heady days of it a decade ago and if we were back to the
days of a decade ago I certainly wouldn't be here before council pleading
with you to help save jobs and there's also a risk things could get worse thank
you very much that my second question is back to Anthony Pestarelli's
presentation he pointed out that the gap pricing gap between a new home and an
existing home a resale for a town home is is like $500,000 so six hundred and
for existing resale versus 1.1 for a new which raises all sorts of questions
about why would anybody buy a new home and is that and yet recognize that
retail is kind of a cap capacity there are new there are no new resales so is
that what's driving this issue that we need to be cognizant of and that could
require us to be trying to stimulate the market and even in a minor tiny way
through the chair fundamentally that is the crux of the issue there is a massive
Delta right now between the market price of housing which is reflected in the
resale market and what it costs to actually build and deliver a home with
all of the taxes from all three levels of government involved and you know
there's work to be done on our side of the ledger in terms of sharpening our
pencils to try to reduce our construction costs to make things more
affordable which would help with the workforce housing certainly if we can
bring bring costs down and some of that's on the material side some of
that's on the labor side although you know reducing labor cost also means
people are making less money which isn't the greatest outcome if Burlington
residents are having fewer dollars come in but on the government side that's
that's why we're here before you today this industry and the jobs we support
we're hoping for good news from the province soon
councilor
I think that should give this council confidence that if DC's are reduced if
DC's are eliminated a hundred percent of that reduction is going to be passed
on to consumers because if that doesn't happen nothing gets built along with
another hundred seventy five thousand dollars of other government funds on
top of that thank you we're hoping for good news from the province soon
councilor currents thank you very much for being here I wanted to pick up on
one of the comments that you made related to an assessment on Burlington
holding significant reserves and I just wanted to know if you were aware that
any offsets that are not picked up by the federal and the provincial
government would have to come out of the taxpayers back pocket this is what the
taxpayers back pocket looks like it's a stabilization reserve fund where our
target is 10 to 15 percent as of September 2025 we held six point three
percent of our revenues so well below that that's the first place we're going
to grab money from next place will be our capital reserve fund that too is
underfunded as well that would be depleted as well first we also put a
two percent infrastructure renewal levy on top of the tax rate for the city
this past year 2026 thank you for referencing Vaughan who had a zero
percent city tax increase and then we would also go to our surpluses at the
end of the year and that traditionally looks like it's appendix B of fin 3625
1.1 to 1.4 million of per year which is about point three to point four percent
of our gross budget so we have nowhere to pull this money from because we are
underfunded in all of those where areas and I'm just wondering what methodology
did you use to determine that Burlington has significant reserves through the
chair you do have a capital reserve in the development charges reserve fund as
do most municipalities across Ontario and the reality is that the amount of
money coming into that fund is going to be declining and they're going to have
to be some difficult decisions made around this horseshoe whether or not you
do anything with development charges going forward the cash cow that
development charges provided in the past is not going to look the same in the
future in terms of your long-term revenue there and every year when you're
working on your operational budgets and your capital budgets there is a certain
degree of property tax assessment growth which I referenced earlier that property
tax assessment growth generally comes through new construction be it
residential or as well on the commercial and industrial side and if we're not
building then there aren't going to be those additional millions of dollars
coming in so I can appreciate your concern regarding which bucket the money
comes from but the reality is that we are looking at a future in which there
is less money coming into the various buckets going forward and unless this
industry gets moving again you're going to have some serious financial issues
going forward great thank you my second question is related to the province and
so I assume you're a lobbyist although I haven't seen you registered on our
lobbyist registry since 2022 but I assume you are in that regard how are
you working with the province when I look at the Financial Accountability
Office of Ontario and they've just released their winter outlook on February
11th 2026 and it's indicating a 7.6 percent unemployment rate which is up
about half just over half a percent from last year is that isolated to your
industry or are we seeing that across all industries and how vocal is your
industry being with getting the support that we need from the provincial
government through the chair I think it's not even across all industries I
think there's two industries in Ontario that have been severely impacted by the
current downturn it's ourselves and it's the manufacturing which certainly
includes the the automotive sector so there's a lot of skilled trades in our
sort of call it blue-collar work and it's targeted in certain municipalities I
think your next-door neighbor and Hamilton's certainly feeling acute
challenges both from the construction slowdown and from some of the
manufacturing slowdown so those are concerning numbers going forward and
certainly we don't want things to get worse in terms of our work with the
provincial governments you know I I should have been with Minister Flack
right now but there's a lot of work through our provincial association and
through ourselves happening with the Ministry of Municipal Affairs and
Housing happening with the Ministry of Finance and a number of other
ministries we are very engaged in a lot of discussions related to housing
enabling infrastructure water wastewater systems looking at different ways of
funding long-term water and wastewater to get them out of the DC's I think the
the public utility model is going to be piloted in Peel region there's a reason
why development charges are only $22,000 in Calgary versus a hundred thousand
plus when you add region and local and most municipalities across the GTA and
they have an entirely different model at West so we are looking at what's working
in other provinces versus Ontario. Sorry, I'm just going to redirect you. I'm just wondering are you having any success with the province
because our first motion that was tabled six months ago almost really was
contingent about being made whole on the province so if you're a lobbyist where
are you on that with the province? I would say that we're making progress yes.
Okay thank you those are my two for now. I see it's mostly second time speaker
did you ask a question yet? Yeah okay I'm going to jump in but the first time
question so one of the concerns certainly that I have is making sure
that any benefit to the reduction of price goes where most needed so not on
luxury condos or homes not on high-end products so had we dealt with this there
I can guarantee you there would have been an amendment to cap the per unit
price and are what are your thoughts around capping that to an affordability
rate? Through the chair depending what that cap figure was so that it captured
enough of the broader market to actually get jobs going get construction going I
certainly don't have a problem with the cap to exclude so-called luxury or
higher-end housing I think that this should be focused on workforce housing
or housing that the the broader you know that Burlington early young Burlington
residents folks moving here sort of that middle-income market can afford. Okay
we're on the same page there my second question is around the right tool and
you touched on it in your delegation information around the difference
between a community improvement plan which is one tool that we have to do a
grant program versus changing the DC bylaw and the concern around the DC
bylaw change is as I understand it but this is a question for you and whenever
we get to the item two weeks from now I'll ask staff but the the concern that
the DC regulations set by the province set the DC rate at site plan which is
not yet construction not shovel in the ground not foundation like that's what
we really want to pursue not you know permits people sitting on approvals and
not actually getting shovel on the ground so do you do you have thoughts
around how we might ensure that this only goes to we've addressed affordability
but also to those that get shovel in the ground to actually build homes within
the two years so through the chair I'm in full agreement with the the city's
strategy and the city's focus that this is a jobs first strategy to try to get
shovels in the ground protect jobs and to get that assessment growth so that
the the city does financially benefit in the long run in terms of the
appropriate tool I'm not particularly fussed on which tool is implemented as
long as that there is certainty on behalf of the proponent if somebody's
going to move forward with a project they have to have certainty as to the
financial outcomes and financial exposure because ultimately if this is
about reducing pricing and I think that's what members of council and the
city wants to see that this is reflected in the purchase price so that that
potential buyer in Burlington is receiving the full hundred percent
benefit there can't be uncertainty that when construction is completed that the
the so-called benefit of the the DC reduction expires or or is revoked so
it's building a box so that there is clarity on when you're in when you're
out and I understand the focus on construction and that there may be
limited tools legally as to how you actually implement this understanding
that you know it gets locked in its site plan generally when people move to site
plan they are planning on proceeding with construction there can be a little
bit of a lag it would be a lot cleaner if we could do this at permits but if it
is it is stuck on site plan that is still a project that's moving forward
just whatever the tool is that is ultimately landed on that there has to
be certainty that there is the path through through the consumer and that
there is no surprise as an adjustment on closing at the end because the grant or
the CIP or the DC reduction was not ultimately provided anybody having a
$13,000 surprise when they close that's not a good surprise okay thank you
Councillor Nielsen you're next. Thank you actually it's related to that so you've
been advocating for the DC's obviously and that's kind of the hot topic versus
the grants but maybe we'll take another look at grants at the CIP grant as well
but you mentioned that like if we go through the developers that they will
reduce their prices accordingly but there and you also mentioned that the
cost of building right now and associated costs and fees is more than
what it would be than what you could charge for it so you want the DC's to
go down in order to get over the hump to make the cost of the house less than the
price that you can charge for it into the market so if we do the DC review
obviously developers are not not-for-profit corporations they need to
make a profit I mean that's that's why they're here so how do we guarantee
doesn't that imply though there's not guarantee that a portion of the DC's
that we would be forgiving will go towards developers profiting through the
chair no a hundred percent would be passed on and that would go the same for
the provincial GST or HST and by way I'll just a basic example if it costs
if the markets at $80 and it cost $100 to deliver a builder a developer cannot
go to any bank with a pro forma saying they're only going to bring in $90 to
build it the banks generally expect a 10 to 15 percent profits they require on
the high-rise side 70 percent of units to be pre-sold they've actually changed
that to about 90 80 percent because now residential construction is perceived to
be so risky that a lot of the large banks won't finance it anymore there are
a lot of projects that are in downtown Toronto that are underwater by hundreds
of millions of dollars so there's a risk profile here but if the DC reduction
brings you from $100 to $90 because it's not going to cover the gap but it
helps that means that the builder or developer can go to the market at the
$90 rate instead of the $100 rate and hope to move a few units I've said
before and I'll say again today that what we're discussing today is not going
to solve the problem it's not going to completely cover that Delta there is a
role there's a more significant role perhaps for the federal and provincial
government to step into this space and there's a lot of advocacy being done at
the provincial and federal governments to take a hard look at GST and HST at
the end of the day it's going to take all three levels of government to cover
that Delta and if we get there the end result is going to be more affordable
housing more of that workforce housing at the lower end of the market and
hopefully more jobs we we have a housing system that's fundamentally broken
because the cost to deliver exceeds what the market is and we're trying to we're
trying to bring the cost down so if we save five bucks from you that five bucks
gets passed on okay so I think we're on the same page then which is you made an
example where it comes down to 90 but actually they need to exceed that by 10
to 15 percent they have to show the profit to go to the bank so that and and
I'm and developers should profit I mean how else would it work in a market
system but doesn't that show that a portion of our DC reduction and HST
reduction which I totally agree has to occur and maybe more provincial support
federal support that's gonna have to go into their profit it has to to go to the
bank so our DC reduction is going to go towards profit through the chair I
disagree with that framing because at the hundred dollar number that I said is
as an example that already includes that 10 to 15 percent profit so if we're
looking at a hundred dollars markets 80 we'll use round numbers so 90 dollars
might be the pure cost to build but the bank is not going to issue the
construction financing loan unless you pull in a hundred so the price is set at
a hundred having built in that ten dollars so the DC reduction comes off
the top if anything actually the DC reduction helps with the profit number
because again using round numbers if the bank expects a ten percent profit and if
you have a hundred thousand dollar development charge which is what a lot
of the rough math is for regional plus local the banks going to expect to see
a ten percent profit on that hundred thousand dollars and the provincial and
federal government because of the way that the HST GST is structured as a
value-added tax charges of 13 percent on that so a hundred thousand dollar DC
results in 13 percent interest so that's immediately 113 thousand and then the
bank is going to require as part of the larger envelope ten percent profit on
that so you're looking at a hundred and twenty three thousand dollars so if you
reduce your DC's by thirteen thousand dollars when you run all the math that
might actually take fourteen or fifteen thousand dollars off the sticker price
okay fair enough my my second question that's it's very related which is again
20 years experience so all this question about whether developers are taking and
again developers need to take a profit in order to work so I totally get it they
deserve a salary as well but what if we did what if we sunk this money this 16
to 41 million dollars into not-for-profit housing then there doesn't
need to be that profit margin in order to go to the bank there's there's
different banks there's the federal bank so and assume some of your members are
not-for-profit builders so would that also create the jobs and allow us to to
deliver affordable housing through the chair this is not going to cost 16 to
42 million dollars I think we you know there was the six point eight million
which was collected last year which already I believe included the building
permit fees etc which we're not talking about reducing so we're talking about a
fraction of that the money coming in in 2026 if nothing is done is going to be
lower than what it was last year and council at any time is free to spend
tens of millions of dollars should you choose to do so on below-income
affordable housing but I certainly haven't seen that in the past so you can
make that decision anytime you would like
I'm going with the staff numbers though I just want to be clear about that thank you
understand
councilor Bentavania
thank you mayor I want to talk a little bit and going back to the supplement
staff memo I want to talk a little bit about the development charges and the
the exposure assumption question number one I learned that what we're talking
about here is not just a two-year freeze because the two-year freeze actually is
expanded to another 18 months and it talks about I can read the whole thing
but I won't but not only would it freeze and to apply to the building permits but
also to development applications and that the reduced eliminate DC rate would
effectively extend beyond the two-year time frame so I mean I'm not sure I mean
I get what this means is that mean that now we have 42 months from the two-year
or in my case I'm just going to ask you if we did one year and when would it be
nine months rating what I would know that so can you comment on how that
would work with through the chair and this may require clarification from
staff but my reading would be you have to go through the door in the two years
and then if you've got the site plan within the two years you have 18 months
to start construction but that doesn't allow somebody to come in on two years
plus a day to walk in that front door so you're still creating a structure where
it's two years to I guess hit that mark that you're in that you're part of the
program and then a period of time to get the shovels in the ground and I think
what that helps do is provide certainty for proponents to be able to adjust
their price lists and be able to sell those units to hopefully get under
construction to sell those 70% of units or you know if it's ground-oriented if
it's a townhome it's much easier to get under construction and I mean to be
blunt I'd be surprised if any high-rises get under construction through this
program but my reading of it is it is only a two-year time period to get in
the door but once you're successfully through the door you've got a little bit
of breathing room to get your affairs in order to get under construction maybe in
the long run that would allow you know any financial exposure of the city to
actually be spread over a longer period than two years which doesn't mean more
money it means whatever the exposure is it's it's spread okay I'm just gonna
pause us there we we are at noon but counselor currency had a point of order
go ahead my point of order thank you very much for acknowledging mayor is in
fact that we are at noon I did indicate at the beginning of the agenda that I
had a hard stop which I still have however I do want to be extremely
respectful of the delegates that are still in chambers and I think we may
need to modify what was identified at the beginning for the hard stop I'm
happy to excuse myself to ten minutes and then hand over the meeting to my
office which is not optimal but it is workable and I just wanted to know if
there is a requirement for a vote to do that by the clerk and that we can move
through lunch since we have a number of delegates still to go I would look to
committee to determine whether you want to pause now or you want to continue to
hear delegations I think we need to take the pause where this will happen this is
happening again in two weeks anyways if delegates would like to stay until one
o'clock they can or else they'll have later the alternative mayors to take a
recess and consult with the delegates about it thank you
councillor Stolti I too would advocate for the pause I'm just realizing that I
didn't time the clock I don't know if the clerk can let us know but our very
first delegate we've been having a question and answer period for I'm
gonna say 45 minutes there's nothing saying that that also won't happen with
our other delegates so without taking lunch we could be still here at 2 30
okay councillor Galbraith I vote I vote to continue I think this delegate being
the CEO of HPA obviously we have lots of questions for him so I would support
continuing right now and if we lose one councillor then I think we still six of
us councillor Sharman well I think I'd like to finish the delegation from the
current delegate and then I think we should take a half hour break no longer
but I do think we need a break okay councillor Bentavania I like to at
least finish my second question and then we could do whatever the committee
decides okay I unless somebody wants to put an alternative motion on the floor
for a vote suggest we complete this delegation then take a break for half an
hour so that includes you but there may be other questions for the delegation as
well okay councillor currents go ahead okay so I'm gonna put a I'm gonna oh
sorry yeah so I'm just looking I don't know if I'm allowed to speak through the
chambers but like Shannon yours is a very fast delegation is that correct you
can wait till after lunch okay after lunch can I get a nod from Delhi okay so
happy to take that break and go with with what has been said so here from
this delegate and then a half hour break okay Angela the floor is yours for your
second question go ahead thank you this was quite a contentious discussion on
the phone and going back to the supplement staff memo it doesn't
mention in this in this supplement staff memo that there is a 51 million
dollars in a DC reserve fund of the which was mentioned at the committee
meeting on Monday of the 51 million dollars in the DC fund 35 million of it
was uncommitted so knowing that we had six point eight million dollars in DC
charges last year and in your delegation you're saying that it will be a fraction
moving forward for 2026 and 2027 if we do the hundred percent and it's already
in the reserve fund do you think 35 million of the un- uncommitted fund will
be sufficient for the two years and then this way it doesn't really cost anybody
any money other than what's in the reserve fund and then once business
kicks in they can rebuild that reserve fund through the normal process you
through the chair I sort of look at this as sort of the the opportunity cost and
understanding that whatever the quote-unquote cost of this is that the
money's not going to be coming in in future years like it was in past years
so whether council chooses to move forward with an elimination of DC's or
whether council chooses not to move forward with an elimination of DC's
there's going to be incredible pressure on that fund and there may have to be
some difficult decisions made about long-term capital projects I think on a
temporary emergency basis there's the opportunity to dip into that reserve
fund keeping in mind that this is temporary and we're in a unique
situation but in the long term I certainly don't advocate for council to
utilize reserve funds I mean that's what it's there for it's collected money in
the past for long-term capital projects and you know the next time you do the
full DC background study because of what's happened in the last couple of
years with the market there may be some different numbers in the long term going
forward in terms of what are your realistic population projections what are
the realistic pressures on long-term infrastructure because I think the
assumptions being made today are different than what the assumptions
would have been made when that DC background study took place so there's
less money coming in but there's also less infrastructure requirements on on
the other side because of the speed and pace of growth and we're also in an
interesting political climate where there are potentially going to be some
major shifts provincially and federally in terms of infrastructure funding just
to follow up so what you say in the next two years of the 35 million what would
you sort of reasonable guess estimate that we would need to pull out of there
knowing that we did six point eight million last year and that includes that
would include building permits as well through the chair you're certainly
putting me on the spot and I I don't know the split between building permits
and not building permits now generally the buildings department is able to fund
revenue and they have their own reserve on on building permits to ensure that
you know wild fluctuations from year to year don't necessarily impact staff
numbers so sort of separating the two because there is a building I'm going to
get the name wrong but a building permit stabilization reserve fund and then you
have the DC Reserve Fund I mean if we get a couple buildings going we could be
looking at three or four million dollars a year but you know we've done
our own poll of members to understand what may or may not be able to get
moving and there's a couple buildings that if approvals go right if the market
turns around and they are able to start selling some units this spring or this
fall at the back end of the two years you might see a couple buildings get
going for the most part I think what this elimination of DC's might be able to
do is some of the ground-oriented product may be able to move more quickly
because you don't have to pre-sell 70 or 80 percent of a building and I think
that's the challenge and that's why we're talking about two years versus one
year that to obtain that bank financing you need a robust sales program so I
hesitate to make a guess it's just it's it's going to be lower than the 6.8 and
lower than whatever the split.
I'll ask that question too. Thank you.
Councillor Stolti go ahead.
Thank you. So Mike a lot of your delegation and your ongoing advocacy which I like
especially given the fact my background is social work and I would love to save
the world if I could I'm sure Charms I know I was waiting for that smart.
The question I have of which Councillor Sharman will appreciate I think because it
goes down his track is when you talk about saving jobs of our residents do
you actually have data regarding how many individuals whose jobs are at risk
are actual residents of Burlington because as much as I would love to save
jobs for everyone how much are we talking about actual Burlington residents
and do you have data that supports that?
In the residential construction industry we sort of talk about regional market
areas so a lot of the data that we have would be for the Hamilton census
metropolitan region area which includes your neighbor to Hamilton you know
borders of municipalities aren't hard lines in terms of commuter sheds so what
is unique about the industry is it is a hyper local industry now that may bleed
over to Oakville Hamilton Milton and here but it also works the other way
around there are residents of Burlington that work in Oakville work in Milton and
work in Hamilton our industry is unique in that you cannot export residential
construction to a plant in China or a plant in Mexico we are an on-site
manufacturers and fabricators that homes in Burlington or the surrounding
regions in which residents of Burlington may go to work on those sites are built
and fabricated on site by people and the supply chains are generally local as
well so they may not be Burlington jobs but any wood that you see going into a
building is generally from North Northern Ontario and any of the concrete
is typically from Milton the Nelson aggregate pit and a lot of the bricks
are you know for example Brampton brick has a plant in Brampton and in Cambridge
so to answer your question the regional market area in terms of jobs bleeds
across municipal boundaries but you have to remember that those Burlington
residents also go to work in Milton or Hamilton as well but it's it is a single
regional market area thank you just to follow up to that do you have an average
salary for workers in the industry are they that would certainly dictate
whether or not they're actually living in Burlington or Hamilton and reaches
that are more affordable than here not at my fingertips but I can get you
statistics Canada data and keep in mind that there's a diversity of jobs so when
we look at on-site skilled trades they are generally paid above the Canadian
average now whether those people can afford homes in Burlington that's a
different question we did a report with dr. Mike Moffat's focused on Hamilton two
years ago that looked at the average salary of a nurse average salary of
somebody driving a bus in Hamilton a number of basic blue-collar jobs and we
found that 10 15 years ago though it was called who will swing the hammer and
that's one of the problems that we have as an industry that increasingly the
people who build our homes are not able to afford the communities that they
actually build in and this is a problem that we have in terms of our workforce
long-term that housing is becoming out of reach from the very people who build
housing okay thank you I'll jump in for a second time question before we go to
third round with councillor Nissan so I just wanted to draw your attention to
attachment be of the response to the mayor's decision for additional
information and table 3 the estimated DC revenues for 2026 so we had the the
range that was provided based on thousands of units coming online and
then we have the sort of the realistic projection so it it has single and
semis at about 128 units those are at the highest DC rate of 21,000 we've got
estimated apartments at 77 those are at 11,000 DC rate and then apartments one
bedroom or less at 115 current DC rate on those is 8700 and then AR use which
don't pay DC's at all nor should they so roughly 400 units in total of which
about 80 are AR use that are DC exempt already so the the cost there being
roughly 4.6 million and lost DC revenue nowhere near the 16 and not even close
to 42 so given what you know from your members is that a realistic picture or
is that even still an optimistic one so through the chair that gives me some
relief that the numbers I provided the previous councillor were within the
range on the staff report from the CMHC numbers given that we're looking at two
years and the crystal ball gets more and more blurry the further away from today
you get I think that those are reasonable numbers in the mid-range if
current trends continue those apartment units certainly aren't going to move
forward but I think if Burlington makes this move and if the provincial
government comes through on some things that were under discussion with them
that this becomes more realistic and then as you get to the tail end of two
years that crystal ball gets a little more fuzzy okay and then attachment C in
answer to the third question in the mayor's decision showed building permit
revenue over the same period that would not be realized if applications don't go
in at 2.9 million dollars against the 4.6 and that doesn't account for
assessment growth I think you mentioned in one building it's over a million
dollars in assessment growth year over year over year so is that and then you
can see some of the specific projects that they're basing the unit count on is
that again based on your members do you think that's realistic to come forward
again the crystal ball is difficult we've done some sampling with members
and you know even our members provide a number of asterisks around if all things
go right in the next two years a couple of them may be able to bring buildings
forward I appreciate your example from the building permit revenue because the
building department has a building permit stabilization reserve fund to
deal with this exact situation and that's what I'm asking for counsel to
consider with the development charges reserve fund that we are in a unique
situation where revenues falling off a cliff and you may need to dip on a
temporary basis into those reserves and then the hope is in 2028 2029 2030 that
that revenue starts coming back in in a big way and in terms of the assessment
growth I mean we're talking about different buckets of money here and you
know my overall concern is all of those buckets are going down we're in a
situation in which revenue will be lower whatever buff that you're talking about
and we're talking about trying to provide some relief in one of those
buckets that may actually bring you more money in the other buckets so if nothing
is done in the grand scheme of things there may be more let that there may be
less financial resources available and we're fighting over the one bucket and
it's you know my concern is sure you'll you'll save some money coming to that
bucket but then you're not going to have any money in the others so I don't know
it's it's it's it's a challenging conversation I understand for all of you
but the revenue projections in the other buckets aren't looking very good and
just as a follow-up you're referring to parkland dedication community benefits
assessment growth which are also in the in this in the response to the staff the
staff response to the mayor's decision what those amounts are all of those
amounts are certainly of concern but the one that I put the most emphasis on is
the the property tax assessment growth the parkland the community benefits all
of these things are important but they're also sort of the the one-time
injection of funds whereas you know if that building at Fairview doesn't get
built you're not just at forty thousand versus 1.5 million this year you're at
that next year the year after and the year after so there are some real
long-term consequences of whether buildings get built or not or even when
buildings get built if a building gets built in 2027 because the city
eliminated development charges temporarily versus that building being
put on hold or canceled and sure maybe it's got the entitlements in place
maybe the market turns and it gets built in 2022 or 2030 you're still losing that
1.5 million over five years and that's 7.5 million dollars over a five-year
period that the city's given up on potential revenue so that you could save
money in one year on development charges and the money in that assessment growth
vastly exceeds the one-time injection in DC revenue thank you
Councillor Nielsen over to you thank you and I'll use a little preamble for my
question here to just caution my my colleagues in asking Mike to answer
questions that may be outside of his expertise we have a CFO who cannot
clarify for you right now in the Q&A but if he could I think he would tell you
that that four million dollar figure is for one year not for two years and 16
million is over two years and that our capital program will have to go down
that this money may not be committed but it is going somewhere and it is tax
dollar money so Mike is a fan is doing a fantastic job and he's an expert at
getting things done for the development industry I'm sorry you missed your
meeting but you are welcome to come back two weeks you didn't have to stay and
please ask Minister Flack to make us whole. Hallett-Holmes you're just talking
about a couple buildings I'm getting confused because Hallett-Holmes wrote a
letter for council today asking us to do this so presumably they plan to take
advantage of it and for everyone's benefit Hallett-Holmes is building the
homes in Millcroft that this that council opposed with Millcroft greens so
they're asking for us to do this so they can build the homes so I suspect I just
would like you to clarify because it sounds like those Millcroft homes are
gonna get built a lot faster if we do this exemption. Through the chair I did
say earlier that the low-rise had a little more predictability versus the
high-rise when you're building if you have a project and I'll use round
numbers again if you have a project with a hundred homes and you're building
single detached homes you can sell those one by one and build them one by
one if you're building a town home block and there's four town homes or five
town homes in them and you've got a hundred you can build that four or five
at a time soon as you're talking about a high-rise building with a hundred and
fifty two hundred three hundred units you need to sell between 70 and 80 percent
of those units to get those under construction so if council does move
forward with this there's a little more certainty when we're making estimates
and forecasts going forward on some activity on the low-rise side with the
high-rise side it is it is more difficult to forecast because yes the
13,000 or $12,000 reduction in the DC's is helpful it's not going to be enough
to clear that whole Delta so there's a whole bunch of other things that have to
also happen in order for projects to move forward so this is an important
conversation that we're having today but we also need help from other levels of
government and as I said earlier we also need to sharpen our pencils on our side
of the ledger. So second and final question agreeing that the market is in
in really bad shape and it has been for some time we still did pull I believe it
was six and a half million dollars I'll get staff to confirm I think it was six
and a half million in DC's last year there will be homes that are going to
get built either way this year even without this reduction right as you said
it's incremental the only difference is we're not going to be collecting those
DC's now and we would have otherwise so do you do you agree that we're gonna
lose revenue that we would have gotten otherwise like or please provide context
of that thank you. Through the chair in some cases yes you might lose some
revenue you would have not gotten otherwise and in other cases you will
enable some projects to move forward that would have not been built otherwise
and you will obtain the long-term property tax assessment growth that I
noted earlier you know this I feel I'm empathetic for staff this is difficult
to have a crystal ball to understand what every dollar here there is going to
do and we don't have a crystal ball over what's going to happen south of
the border and that obviously impacts market sentiment as well. Thank you. Some
of the sorry some of the six point eight million dollars that moved forward you
know some of those projects were able to move forward in a tough economic
circumstances and some of those other projects some of the projects that moved
forward may have sold most of their units in 2021 2022 when the market was
pretty good and still had an additional couple steps to go in terms of approvals
or maybe they were at 60% sales and they needed to get those last few so
housing starts I always say are a lagging indicator because they they even
though that's when the jobs are created and that's sort of the good news around
this table in terms of the jobs being created and and the money coming in
terms of DC's from sort of the way that we look at things those represent
yesterday's sales and my concern is looking at Urban Nation or Altus or
Zonda sales numbers and just how much of a cliff they went off in 2025 so as we
look forward into 2026 and 2027 we don't have the sales numbers that are going to
generate those starts. So quick follow-up as the mayor noted table three estimated
DC revenues 2026 that's based that's one year and that's based on not doing a DC
reduction or exemption or elimination and that's four point six six million
dollars of foregone revenue is that right maybe I should ask that for staff
actually I'll ever track the question I'll make sure staff get this right.
Through the chair if you look at the trend line though in 2024 you had
eleven point one million in revenue and then it goes down to the six point eight
recognizing that includes some building permit revenue so in one year from 2024
to 2025 your revenues dropped almost in half. I agree I don't think DC's are the
best way to do this. We're into comments now. Councillor Stolti. Thank you mayor so
actually I appreciate the segue of Councillor Nielsen's questions because
that's kind of where I was headed to I think we all have a different
perspective on what's fair and reasonable but from my perspective
sitting in the seat on fair and reasonable I really struggle with that
idea that the homes being built at Millcroft could avail themselves of a
potential program as it was passed last week and I'd like to get your thoughts
on do you think it's fair and reasonable to put a condition that the DC charge
reduction would be applicable only on projects that have been approved by the
City Council and not on projects that have been appealed to OLT against this
city council's wishes? Through the chair I don't want to speak to individual
projects because frankly there are a lot of projects that have had to go through
the tribunal some of those projects this council opposed other projects there
was no decision made in the appropriate time so those projects may have been
appealed due to a non decision so we're really getting into the weeds there
perhaps a solution to that particular issue is the mayor asked a question
earlier about an upset limit in terms of luxury versus non luxury homes. Okay
thank you. Yeah that's where my last question was going to go I just looked
up how at homes and they bill their entire product as a luxury market there
so knowing that you know the industry and you know pricing do you have any
thoughts for us what a reasonable cap might be or a range of a cap might be to
eliminate entirely the luxury product on Millcroft which which none of us want to
see go forward for a whole bunch of other reasons myself included? Through
the chair I want to emphasize that I am not commenting on a specific project but
I believe in the CMHC presentation last week and forgive me I don't have it in
front of me but I believe that there was a number around the average in
Burlington being around 1.75 1.8 something like that and recognizing
that yes that does look like a big number but that is the market reality if
you want to encompass middle-class housing that is what is being built in
Burlington perhaps that would be a fair number that would encompass most of the
multi-unit including entry level and you know that move up where somebody is
perhaps in a condo they've got a kid there's another one on the way they
don't want to move out of Burlington they want to stay in Burlington and be
able to have that move up product and then perhaps that solve some of the
optics or challenges around the higher-end product would then be
excluded. Okay and then my final question again based on your expertise
around what you know of your members and who's building what and that lag from
that lag over time the CMHC at pipeline to permit said 2027 is where things
would really fall off a cliff and I'm just wondering if the what what you are
hearing from your members around if if it's 400 units and roughly 4.6 million
exposure for next year and that doesn't include all the revenues that would be
lost as well if nothing gets built what what does the picture look like for 2027
for you do you know yet? Through the chair I mean it's it's pretty doom and
gloom out there our members are laying off a lot of people we have some
companies that are that used to do high-rise and low-rise and they've laid
off their entire high-rise staff because they don't plan on participating in that
market segment anymore because they don't see a future so the crystal ball
is pretty tough the general mood is that 2026 is going to be worse than 2025 and
anybody that's talking about recovery is talking about 2028 2029 versus 2027
I mean I'm hopeful that we've hit bottom and we're starting the the curve upwards
I hesitate to provide a projection on 2027 because I believe that this
council is going to do the right thing and and move forward with a temporary
exemption to respond to the current conditions and then remove that
exemption as things shift back to normal and I'm fairly optimistic with the
advocacy happening at the provincial government that the province is
actually going to do something and that will hopefully move the market get some
sales in the latter half of this year and that's why I appreciate that we're
talking about two years versus one year for better for worse construction
approvals these kinds of things take time and a two-year window perhaps even
with that site plan that you get in the window but then you've got a little bit
of a gap to get your if there is an order in terms of the construction I
believe is an appropriate window to try to deal with the issue at hand thank you
councillor Stolti thank you sorry I needed some clarity on the answer that
you gave the mayor I wasn't sure I was hearing correctly so I appreciate that
your commitment earlier on behalf of your members that DCU reductions should
be focused on workforce housing projects as opposed to luxury high-end you did I
understand you correctly that you think that the average home price new home
price of 1.8 million should be where the cap is I believe and I don't remember
off the top of my head but the CMHC presentation that we saw last week had
1.8 is the average in Burlington but I don't have the presentation in front of
me but that was the number that you were thinking the cap should be because that
would cover the broader middle class to to get things moving again recognizing
that this is temporary okay all right not seeing any other questions so you
are free to go bring a water next time yes sorry we should have gotten you a
glass of water I apologize all right we are now in recess until one o'clock and
back to hear from the rest of our delegations thanks everyone
you
welcome back everyone we're gonna get started again after our brief break for
lunch we still are continuing with some delegates so what I would like to do now
is call up our next pre-registered delegate. Let me just find who that is.
All right Jim Thompson, there you are. Thank you. In chambers speaking to two
items you'll have five minutes apiece. The first you can do it in whichever
order you like. One is the options for the temporary elimination of development
charges and the other is regarding the council code of good governance and
staff relations policies. So Jim the floor is yours and there may be
questions after. Go ahead.
Sir your microphone. There you go. First of all I'd like to say that staff was
working on the weekend. I got a response from Debbie about my presentation being
on the agenda that they had so thanks to her for going over and above. So good
morning Mary Ann and councillors. There is a crisis in the residential
construction industry in the GTA and the Golden Horseshoe. This is largely because
of provincial government policies about how development is funded in Ontario.
There are problems with federal policies as well but they're not impacting other
provinces the way they are impacting Ontario. I don't believe it is the role
of the Burlington Council to solve the industry's problems by throwing money at
them. I can support the city advocating on behalf of the industry to both the
provincial and federal governments but I cannot support the mayor's motion to
stop collecting development charges for a period of two years. Failure to collect
development charges will result in inflated property taxes in future years.
The money has to come from somewhere as Councillor Neeson said at the committee
of the whole meeting. This council has increased property taxes by 45% in the
last four years. This is the affordability crisis that is affecting
current Burlington homeowners. Giving a $20,000 gift to someone buying a
$2 million home is not a means of improving affordability. I'm going to
say that there's also a problem with the development charge being suspended for
two years. It's not a cyclical problem in the industry which the two years seems
to suggest. It's a structural problem. The way rental housing has been financed in
the country for many years has stopped the development of rental housing which
is the affordable option for most workers. Too many people can't
afford a house because wage productivity has not capped up with the cost of
housing. Housing has been turned into a financial asset, not a place to live. So
I can't support this idea that Burlington won't collect taxes so that
it can assume a leadership position on the issue which is supposedly going to
benefit political pressure on the provincial government and federal
government. That's not your job. It's not your job to use Burlington's taxpayers
reserve funds to put pressure on the provincial and federal governments. Thank
you for your time. Thank you. I will just look to the board to see if there are
questions. You have two so far. Councillor Nielsen, you're first. Just one question
to the chair. Thank you Jim for delegating first of all. So if the
motion were amended to say conditional upon being made whole, would you be
supportive of it as a Burlington resident? I have no problem if you can get
the federal government and the provincial government to pay for it but
good luck with that because the federal government has got a 1.2 trillion dollar
debt and an 80 billion dollar deficit and the provincial government is
approaching 500 million dollars in debt and has a 13 to 14, sorry that's billion
dollars, 13 to 14 billion dollars in deficit. So where's the money coming from?
Any way that you go about this, it comes out of the Canadian taxpayer.
Thank you Jim. Councillor Coons. Through the mayor, thank you for being here with us today Jim. So one of the things that the municipality has the option to do is to place a referendum question on the election ballot in October 2026. Would you feel that this is enough of a huge question like should development charges be eliminated?
For a referendum question for the public to vote on? That's an engagement question
so I understand why you're asking it and yeah I think that you need to get public
input when you're looking at blowing potentially a 40 billion dollar, a 40
million dollar hole in your capital projects budgets and I'd like to be
clarify I don't think the property the fees for permits are part of the part of
the development charges they're a separate reserve fund which you've been
drawing down on heavily. Correct thank you thank you very much thanks for being
here. Councillor Stolti. I thank you again for your delegation. So a question. Could the volume get raised a bit please?
So thank you again for your delegation and a question in regards to your
statement which I fully agree with that we should be expecting the province of
the federal government to make us whole what would that commitment look like in
your eyes are you comfortable with that being a verbal handshake or would you
prefer to see a signed contract? The job's not finished till the paperwork's done.
The mayor's made a point that stuff needs to get papered well this is
something that needs to get papered. Fool me once shame on shame on you fool me
twice shame on me. While George Bush had a good mistake on that one he said you
can't fool me twice you got fooled once on bill 23 why are you getting letting
yourself get fooled again? Okay thank you very much. All right not seeing any other
questions on this item you can speak to your next one which is the code of good
governance you'll have another five minutes go ahead. Okay could I get my
presentation up please?
No my presentation it's a PDF.
My presentation was in for the deadline on Friday why didn't it make it into the
minutes or the agenda? We'll just give our staff a minute to find that and get
it up for you.
Okay.
Apparently I submitted the wrong presentation. So okay so don't really
need it. I would like to get what I did provide what I did provide was a
spreadsheet that shows the policies and procedures of the council that are out
of date that haven't been reviewed many of them for years and I my first slide
was actually going to be the Municipal Act and I'm going to just assume that
you know it a little bit. The role of council is defined in the Municipal Act
is to develop and evaluate the policies and programs of the municipality to
ensure that administrative policies practices and procedures and
controllership policies practices and procedures are in place to implement
the decisions of council and in subsection to ensure the accountability
and transparency of operations of the municipality including the activities
of the senior management of the municipality. With regards to development
of policies you have developed some new policies but you've utterly failed to do
your duty to evaluate the existing policies. With regards to part D there
are policies in place but you fail to hold a staff accountable for
following the policies. The data slide shows which the data side shows that of
the 79 policies listed on the City of Burlington website 63 have not been
reviewed in a timely manner that's 80% of the policies listed. At least two
policies pertaining to the council staff relations policy aren't even listed on
the website specifically the employee code of conduct and the respect in the
workplace policy. In addition two policies are utterly lacking review by
dates and I didn't have time to figure out how many of the job titles in the
accountability and responsibility columns don't correspond to the current
organizational structure. The enterprise risk and government and
management policy indicates that it was supposed to be reviewed every two years
it was last reviewed in 2020 that's six years ago. The IT security policy also
hasn't been reviewed since 2020 given what happened in Hamilton shouldn't
review of this policy have been a priority. In my opinion council needs to
review policies at least once per term this is implicit in the role of council
to evaluate policies as prescribed in the municipal act. I note that when the
audit committee updated their terms of reference they added an as needed
option not not just a fixed review date. One of the needed changes that the audit
committee made was to change the title of city manager to chief administrative
officer. Major organization changes require a lot of paperwork not just an
organization chart that has half the positions unfilled. Staff has been
directed has been derelict and providing timely reports. Council has been derelict
in ensuring that management systems are working properly. These are two of the
these are two of the things that are in your council staff relations policy.
You need to do more than just add it's going to happen I guess but this needs
to be a thorough review of that policy because you haven't been doing it and
the next slide was in regards to the code of good governance and I'm not
clear on what staff has been directed to do regarding this policy. At a minimum I
think it needs to be updated to properly document the complaint procedure there
is no form to fill out it's just an email to the integrity commissioner. I
looked at the region's code of conduct and it's certainly more detailed than
Burlington's but I wasn't impressed with the clarity and of the way it's written
and one of the points that the integrity commissioner made in her last report to
council was that more explanation examples and commentary are needed to
assist the reader. I also believe the council needs to get an annual report
from the integrity commissioner there hasn't been one since 2023 and
those are if there has been a report it's not put up on the website for
people to see and I also think that any report that comes from the integrity
commissioner should be up. Thank you you are out of time but I will pause to see
if there are any questions from anyone. Councillor Currence. Thank you for being
here today and for bringing this I did receive a circular of this PDF over the
weekend so thank you Debbie and we're glad that it came up today. When it was
asked about in committee the acting CAO identified that they heard about outdated
and a plan was to be prepared and brought back to council where quarterly
reports will resume. It did not indicate anything around prioritization of the
outstanding policy updates or a timeline. Do you think that this is acceptable?
Frankly Councillor Nissen made a good effort but it does need a staff
direction for them to do it. It's not just council needs to get these
policies to be reviewed in a timely manner and it's not happening and you
need to take corrective action at this point and frankly I don't even know if
putting it on the staff directions list does any good because there hasn't been
a staff direction policy update released for I don't know how long. The last the
last one I have was maybe back in 2024. This is something that's the
responsibility of the clerk to issue the table that he's supposed to be keeping
regularly. This should not be a major issue it's just a table that needs to
get updated. There was some attempt made to prioritize the issues under the
last CAO but it didn't result in timely reporting and this is a problem.
Council doesn't keep a record for itself they rely on staff and
staff isn't doing their job. Okay thank you for those insights and I did look up
some policies that haven't been updated like the ability to work on weekends so
that I knew if I was stepping over a line with staff by trying to ask
questions on the weekend about this so thanks for being here and bringing this
to our attention. Not seeing any other questions thank you very much for being
with us. I'd like to say that if I get the stuff in on time it should get
onto the agenda and and I would have known that I'd put in the wrong the
wrong the wrong file. Thank you. Okay our next delegation Shannon Gillies is in
chambers to speak to a heritage response to bill 23 phase 2 shortlist of
designation candidates DGM 726 you have five minutes and there may be questions
go ahead. My narrative about my house seems inconsistent with all the serious
and development charge things we were talking about but serious to me so so
good afternoon Mayor Mead Ward and members of council and staff my name is
Shannon Gillies and I along with my husband Bill Charney are the owners of
1419 Ontario Street and I'm here to communicate some concerns we have about
the staff report entitled heritage response to bill 23 phase 2 shortlist of
designation candidates which includes our home ranked as number 2 of 10
recommended properties to be studied. A bit of background in the fall of 2001
Bill and I decided we wanted to buy a house with character not a cookie cutter
house in a new subdivision. When 1419 came up for sale we were charmed not
only by the house itself but also by the people who lived there. We found out that
Minnie Walker had lived in that home for over 40 years with her late husband
George and their four children which we're still amazed at because we're
stepping all over each other still and there's only two of us. When we noticed
an upright base on display in the front hallway we learned that Mr. Walker had
once been a band member at the Branton. In the months following September 11th
which is when we bought the house when the future seemed uncertain there was
something comforting about moving into a house that had stood in the same place
since 1907 mostly unchanged while the world around it injured two world wars
and other transformative events of the 20th century. Over the years we've spent
a small fortune relatively on upkeep that wouldn't have been necessary in a
new home. We replaced all the wiring, switched our furnace from oil to gas,
built an entirely new garage because the existing one had caved in. We paid to
have radon and basement flooding mitigation systems installed as well as
for asbestos removal and even bat proofing. A few years ago we had the
pleasure of spending thousands to dig a trench in our front yard to have an old
rusted out water supply pipe replaced and the city didn't pay for any of this
it was on our part of the property. We paid for this these things because it's
our home and it was our choice to assume all the risks and the responsibilities
that come with owning an older house. My point here is that we chose to buy a
century home nearly 25 years ago because we wanted a century home and we've
chosen to continue to invest in it because we love it most days and plan
to stay here indefinitely. We never had a problem with being on the municipal
registry of non-designated heritage homes because we knew we'd never need
to apply for a demolition permit. Provincial bill 23 is intended to remove
barriers to building more new homes in neighborhoods slated for higher density.
Our house is not at risk of demolition to build a condo. I wrote here I don't
know what the current maps show for zoning but the last I checked it was a
few streets west of Brant Street but didn't go as far as our part of herd.
Today I'm asking you to remove our home from the list of ten properties to be
studied for designation eligibility or at the very least defer your vote on this
matter until next month to allow for more discussion for the following reasons.
The notices to the ten property owners were not received in time for any of us
to prepare a response before last week's committee meeting. As it was already
mentioned we got our notice on Friday right as the meeting was happening so I
was pretty disappointed about that and I ended up watching the meeting I think it
was the next day and there was no discussion on this topic whatsoever. The
rushed forced designation of our home but not others nearby simply isn't fair
and while legal constitutes government overreach our neighbors are free to
modify their homes on either side of us because they're not designated even
though there's similar in age and we would have we would have limitations if
we want to build a small extension or do any kind of external work we'd have to
apply for the permit and not be sure that it would be approved. We will
continue to object to a designation even if we need to appeal at the OLT which
will cost cost the city additional funds unfortunately. We are happy to have our
house added back onto the municipal registry my understanding is in six
years I'm not sure if my math I'm not sure if it's five years from January
2027 so we're happy to put it back on the list at that time or have the city
do that. So in our opinion the city has not been proactive enough in encouraging
voluntary voluntary designation. I sent a link to what Guelph has done they sent
out a bunch of letters and they got some responses of people who wanted to
voluntarily designate their house. So in closing it brings me no joy to delegate
today against Heritage Protection because I do respect all the work being
done by staff and Heritage Burlington Advisory Committee. I hate to see the
loss of beautiful buildings as much as anyone else and I know the city's been
put in a difficult position. Thank you you do have a couple of questions first
from Councillor Stolti go ahead. Thank you Mayor. Thanks Shannon thanks for
being here today. So I'm sure you I know that you were here and hearing all the
conversation that was earlier so that and that was in large part why I had
advocated successfully thankfully for the complete agenda to be referred at
least until or deferred at least until March 2nd in order to have time to talk
more but then just about the DC charges so does that give you some level of
comfort that there won't be a decision made today and that we're into next
next month's decision. My preference would it would be that it goes back to
committee so it can actually have a robust discussion and and then go to
the council meeting after that. Okay but the deferral at least today helps in
that process. Okay thank you. Councillor Currens. Thank you very much through the
chair I was just gonna ask the same question would you support a deferral
back to committee or a referral back to committee which is the full cycle not
straight to council so two-step process so take it out of this put it back into
the March committee of the whole and then from March committee of the whole
it would go to March council meeting for determination. I think that's what I would
prefer I realize time is limited but at least it gives me and some other
homeowners a chance to talk about this at committee. Yeah it gives me a chance
to because you were not the only person who was surprised and we've had some
communication with staff so I will bring it forward at the appropriate time but
thank you for at least being open to that option. Councillor Nisan. Thank you
thank you very much. Your property number again was 1419 Ontario Street
it's right at the corner of Herd on the northwest corner. Perfect so I just want
to make sure that we're all on the same page so you're you know you're not going
to be designated through the council meeting right that it's yeah I know it's
the first step right to be studied to have a look at it yeah okay good and you
mentioned something about I think you mentioned something about going back on
to onto the register did I hear that correctly? Yes and I hope I have my
information right my understanding is that this new bill will if the city
doesn't designate the homes by January 2027 I guess it is then I'm there was
something about a two-year period I'm not sure about but then my understanding
was that after five years the houses can go back on a municipal registry of
non-designated homes. Oh I'm not sure if anyone can confirm that. Well definitely
ask staff my understanding is that the registry is going to become null. That's
what I thought at first and then as I was reading it I was reading more about
this five-year thing that that houses could go back on a on a municipal
registry of non-designate houses after five years. So we'll definitely ask at
council okay does that change your mind at all if if like that's not even an
option like it's either my understanding it's either up or down like we have to
make that call we got a we got an extension to the deadline and we study
the properties and it's either yes or no and and that's the end essentially. I'm
only mentioning it because as a way of suggesting to council that you know my
house isn't at risk of being demolished we're going to be there another six ten
fifteen years and so when I read that about the houses going back on the
registry I thought why bother designating our house designate another
house protect another house. I see okay thank you Shannon. Thanks I'll just jump
in are you asking us not to study it at all or you're okay with it? Yes because I know what's going to qualify. You know what's going to qualify for designation.
Essentially is what I was you know. Okay so delaying the discussion and put
another house on instead. Okay choose another house of your top ten to study I
know that there's limited funds or $75,000. I see. So you would want us to
ask staff if there's another house that could be studied for the funds versus
your house. Yeah one that's more at risk in the in the high density area I don't know I'm not
haven't studied this thoroughly I don't know if there's any other houses on
Brandt Street that qualify like I know you haven't been able to pick all the
houses because money and time is short so you've been scrambling and the city's
been scrambling so in my eye I think why not protect a house that's more at risk
of demolition like on Brandt Street because that's where the zoning is for the condos to go. They're
not going to build a condo on my lot. Okay thank you. Councillor Currins. Thank you once again through
the mayor so I hear you loud and clear however you are also located directly across the street
from the new heritage character area. Yeah. Is that something that maybe needs to be expanded
to the north side of Ontario as opposed to just the south side and that would eliminate the
concerns around heavy-handed heritage designation so in Ward 2 and in the downtown in particular
of St. Luke's which is where you're located the heritage conversation has not always been an easy
conversation it's been softened the edges of it around the heritage character where you just need
a sort of heritage permit as opposed to the full heavy-handed designation which does a lot more
than just a you know paint colours and shutters. Is that something you would be more open to around
that type of a thing? Yes I thought about that because I realize now that houses directly across
from us are in the map for the heritage district because I don't think they were before
but I wouldn't want our house just to be included I would want either house on either side of us the
beautiful house on the other side of Heard which has much more of a historical story than our house
does but it doesn't qualify because they've done some extensions out the back but I would love to
see that house and the house on the other side of us if they were all included all in the heritage
district that would change things because I think that would be much more equitable for us because
then we're not at a disadvantage for potential buyers there's more value there for buyers they're
part of a beautiful heritage district they know nothing's going to happen to either house with
our house you know we have a sister house they call it a twin house or something next to us
it's basically the identical house with with modifications but it's not protected right now
and ours will be and it's just it's not fair that they can do they don't have any of those
restrictions and across the street the house can take off the full frontage and replace the whole
deck and you can't touch yours right I mean and we're probably not going to do anything major but
it's just having that freedom to you know we're getting older our parents are getting older one
day we might need to put a small extension out the back with a bedroom in a bathroom we don't
have a main floor bathroom right now and it just you know and I know the argument would be that
well you know staff is flexible and they're reasonable but I don't know that right there's
no guarantees and I don't know what the council is going to be like in subsequent years who is
going to decide on some of these things okay thanks for your patience today okay I'm not
seeing any other questions thank you so much for joining this morning okay our next delegate is
David Barker to speak regarding options for the temporary elimination of development charges come
on up David you have five minutes and there may be questions
okay
thank you for the minute I was going to say good morning seems a bit superfluous now right
I am amazed and extremely disappointed that City Council is willing to give away or effectively
give away according to staff figures between 17 and just over 41 million of anticipated revenue
by way of waiving development charges for a two-year period the only way this loss of revenue
revenue can be absorbed is through higher property taxes my position on this as you might already
tell is that development charges should not and I repeat not be eliminated no matter what the time
period the elimination period before I have two reasons for saying this position the first reason
being that if development charges are eliminated the cost to install services usually covered by
development charges will fall upon the property taxpayer why should the property taxpayer
bear these charges for which it gets no benefit because it won't be in those houses it's easy
for council to vote to eliminate development charges because council does not pay the bill
property taxpayers pay the bill my second reason I guess is more to do with my upset with the
developers as a whole commercial businesses are there to be to make a profit at customers expense
that is understood and accepted by society if however businesses a business is unable to make
a profit it more than likely would go out of business sure there are instances where a
governmental body may step in to bail out a failing business because of the effect a failure would
have on society and the rest of the economy at large in such cases provincial and federal
governments have funds available giving them the ability to bail out the corporation sure those
funds do come from taxpayers but the load is spread over a much larger tax paying base
our municipal government does not have any such resource available to it any elimination of
development charges will fall directly and immediately upon the existing tax base so in
effect the existing tax base is subsidizing to some extent the purchaser of the new home
that the developer will be building why should that be my feelings towards developers is not a kind one
why is that well in my view over the last 10 years or so developers have been raking in great
profits on their developmental projects whilst at the same time totally ignoring the wishes of
burlington residents and their council as regards to zoning and height restrictions
they have in effect shown burlington the middle finger now they come crying and wanting our help
which will allow them to continue showing us the middle finger and ignoring our wishes and zoning
bylaws certainly we do not certainly we do not need developers sorry certainly we do need
development developments built and new affordable homes made available to the population hopefully
the developments will include large numbers of affordable rental houses but i doubt that
my solution is to allow property developers a deferral not an elimination of development charges
for which they are responsible i would suggest a deferral be until such time as the development
is completed a certificate of occupancy is issued and 75 is sold or occupied at which time deferral
at which time deferral fees so development fees would be payable in full in my opinion our council
should be saying no to eliminating development charges and only allowing a deferral if really
needs be but council should be pushing back on developers directing them towards the provincial
and federal governments whose taxes and other charges are more significant at the committee
of the whole three councillors voted in favor of the elimination of development charges two voted
against and two councillors kerns and shaman were absent i am hoping my delegation here is not in
vain and that councillors kern and shaman will vote with councillors nissan and stolte to defeat
the motion hopefully you're not hopefully you're not only hearing my voice and the voices of
financially strained constituents but you're listening and you will send the matter back
to staff for further consideration thank you for your time thank you very much i am not seeing any
questions for you okay wait councillor kerns thank you just yeah through the mayor my question to
you is this so you're pretty keen observer of council proceedings do you feel that this
issue or the magnitude which you've mentioned from our staff's numbers have made it into
mainstream communications well enough for a media release by the city or anything like that to alert
regular taxpayers what the magnitude of this is not at all not at all i came across it by luck
but just through an article on focus burlington okay i had no idea okay and then if there were
do you feel that this would be an issue that would be of a magnitude sufficient enough to warrant
a referendum question on the election ballot in october 2026
some sort of question would be good but a single question won't get you a proper answer because
people have variances so it needs to be almost like a multi-choice question what are your
preferences and then if it's possible to rank rank those and see where people stand so i'm going to
stop you because that's not an option it's a yes no question do you it would be something like
should development charges be eliminated yes no i don't see why it shouldn't be on there
okay thanks for your time i think you have someone else councillor charman thank you very much and
just picking up on that thought process about having enough information to make a decision
um are you did you did you see by any chance the the presentation that was provided by the cmhc
uh person that talked about the act their projection of the number of units that would be
maybe uh built no i haven't seen so so i'm just against it in principle i think it's the wrong
thing to do to eliminate to her no no i but you didn't see the data sorry you didn't see the data
no right and so therefore did you know that it was a whole lot less than 16 well it's one dollar or
a hundred dollars or a million dollars doesn't matter the principle is wrong we we the residents
should not be bailing out a commercial business they have other places to go to get money and
that's the provincial and federal governments thank you for the clarification did you know that
if i might follow up on that that in the uh in in the housing price differential between a resale
home and a new home there's 200 000 of government source funding that in other words payments to
government sorry point of order this is a good question of clarity on the delegation
i i'm not about introducing information hold on hold on wait she's called a point of order
okay so one at a time i think it's relevant to the conversation so go ahead counselor sherman
thank you so are you aware though that in terms of the difference the amount of money that's
being collected by government on a resale home versus a new home is about 200 000 dollars that
so so that a buyer of a resale home would not have to give 200 000 so shouldn't that be given
some thought also so you're saying the resale home is a higher price lower by 200 000 dollars
i'm not going back to the presentation i think someone said the difference is like
eleven thousand dollars it'll make to the price so the sale price that the developer will have
by deferring or eliminating the development charges will be roughly eleven thousand dollar
difference yeah i think you've answered the question thank you that makes it makes no sense
if you're paying 400 000 dollars eleven thousand is nothing okay thank you uh counselor nason
thank you your worship since we're going to allow the did you knows i'm going to add a couple more
and did you knows sorry did you know david that staff stand by their estimates that this will
cost between 16 and 41 million dollars did you did you know that i know that was a number was
given out if they stand by it it makes it even more reason why not to do it so who who's as a
follow-up who whose numbers do you think council should uh i don't think any of our colleagues or
of our staff i think eliminating development charges in principle is wrong defer them
but these developers they've made millions i mean uh the guy who's sitting here today um
more than i i mean he's not poor and now he's having a tough time he wants us the taxpayer
to bail him out i don't want to do that thank you david thank you uh to council second question
did you know that there's more money collected for hst which goes into general revenue on these
new homes than for development charges which goes back into the community were you aware that
in burlington the hst is actually higher so i'm not not understanding you on a new house yeah the
provincial and federal government did you know that they collect hst on that and it's more than
our dcs yes that's why i say that's the place to go and get some some help from the provincial and
federal governments who are set up to bail out companies if they need to be bailed out and there
is an effect on society or on the economy at large thank you councillor bentovania
thank you mayor and thank you david for being here um
you are aware that at times the economy needs to be kick-started sorry you are aware that at times
the economy needs to be kick-started yes we know that the the housing industry as was mentioned
numerous times has fallen off the cliff we've talked about last year's development charges
and i know you said whether it's a hundred dollars or the true number was 6.8 million collected
we are going to collect less based on all the information that we have that many of us have
talked about for the last few hours and there's been discussion of fraction to half so again going
back to the reports from 16 million to 40 million do you see an issue with those numbers and not
an issue with those numbers and i don't know i know nothing about the numbers i can't speak
to whether they're valid or not but you say less development charges will be coming in
does that mean less buildings going on i assume so so the infrastructure is not going to be needed
because they're not being built so lack of development charges means the lack of need
to put in the infrastructure because it's not being built is that not not logical that actually
is very logical but we need to build homes yes but that's not our job as a taxpayer
it's a fun hang on hang on we're not gonna not having a conversation here do you have another
question yeah i do i do have another question so do you believe that we need to build homes
so that we could build the tax base by putting people in those homes so that
we can get the growth that we need in terms of financial to build not only roads for these homes
but infrastructure facilities and so on so with limited revenues that we would have with no homes
being built do you believe that the taxpayer the existing taxpayer is going to pay more money
moving forward if you're going to eliminate no if they if there's less homes being built in the
next two years yeah which that's is the existing taxpayer you and i
going to pay more in the next two years than we would normally pay if there was growth
uh i don't i don't believe we would be paying more because the development charges will be
covering those expenses no just we don't want to we can't have a conversation here but there's
no homes being built so so so there's no there's no development charges coming in there's no
infrastructure costs needed because there's no houses being built okay thank you uh offline
yeah yeah well we'll move on uh councillor stolte go ahead um thank you i'll throw out my own uh did
you know or were you aware were you aware in the staff report that staff are recommending uh
exploring a development charge deferral or or wave program that was focused only on two plus
bedroom family size purpose-built rentals and would you see your way to thinking that that might be
worth exploring more not not funded by burlington residents funded by the ontario government and the
federal government absolutely that's a wider base of taxpayers funding whether it's burlington
milton osho doesn't matter burlington should not residents should not be funding
a commercial entity to build something make a profit because they're still talking about making
a was it their eight to ten percent profit why am i funding him to make a profit that's what a
business is meant to do if you can't do it somebody else will come and build it okay thanks
councillor charman thank you very much david i'm thinking about your consistency uh that you
don't want the developers to receive a reduction in the um development charges if those development
charges reduction caused that price to be lower and it's not a gift to the developers but to the
new homeowner would that make a difference to you well i think the number put out by the developers
is it'll make an eleven thousand dollar difference that is meaningless if you're like my daughter
elder daughter lives in liberty village okay it's toronto i'm sorry put aside the number
i was asking you about the principle what's the cost of the of the unit being sold so my question
is if that was going not to the developer but to the homeowner to give them a reduction in price
would that change your perspective i don't believe so because i ask you what is the price of the sale
let's say it's let's say it's 600 000 i'm sorry i can't have a debate with you no no but eleven
thousand dollars on 600 000 is meaningless fine thank you thank you councillor currents
thanks very much for sharing uh your philosophy so i'm just looking at some articles here and
we're seeing things like i mentioned the unemployment rate from the province's own
financial report at 7.6 percent a survey of restaurants in canada finds that 44 percent
of respondents are operating at a loss or even breaking eve or barely breaking even
i know firsthand from our retail main street businesses that they are struggling with empty
stores and significant losses in in retail do you think we should be bailing out at the local level
everybody who needs who needs a hand because if we lose our restaurants if we lose our businesses if
we lose our houses then we will all have nothing so i'm just wondering where does it end
when we haven't even called a housing crisis in the city i don't believe we taxpayers should be
funding any commercial entity so if a cafe is going out of business who's owned by a couple
of private individuals you want to fund that i don't believe so what about if i can't afford
my groceries are you going to fund my groceries for me you know why not it's not the job of the
municipality to save businesses it's the job of the provincial government and the federal government
to do that great thank you very much thank you all right uh not seeing any other questions i do
just have one for you and you mentioned um what i thought was your and this is a clarity question
what i thought was your support for a deferral of payment until occupancy of development charges
and i'm just wondering if you know that that is already um that is already policy of the government
that those development charges aren't due to the city until occupancy and that is a surcharge on
the purchaser's price it goes direct to the purchaser so it doesn't actually subsidize the
developer so are you aware of that does that change your thought at all sorry i understand
you're saying there is a deferral already yes that's provincial policy so so what so what do
the developers want they've gotten a deferral and then you want an elimination of them as well
so you mentioned in your i'll start again because we can't have a debate or a discussion so if i
wasn't clear in my question i apologize i'll start again you mentioned that i thought you were
supportive of a deferral of payment until occupancy and so i was wondering if you were
aware that that is already provincial legislation that has changed recently that dcs are not payable
to the city until occupancy and they're added to a closing to the cost of the purchaser so it
doesn't go through the developer doesn't subsidize the developer it goes from the purchaser at
occupancy to the city does that change so did you know that i guess i did not know that and
okay i assume that closing that amount would be known before closing well before so it's not going
to come as the gentleman said like a surprise you know it's not like oh we're going to have to pay
eleven thousand dollars now we didn't think we're going to have to that would all be disclosed up
front on us we'll assume in the purchasing sale agreement okay so as long as it's disclosed you're
okay with it all right thank you very much there are no further questions for you thank you so much
for coming in again and our final delegation lynn crosby please come up you have five minutes
and there may be questions oh uh sorry go ahead councillor nissan thanks just as lynn's coming up
i would just ask you know request of the chair to adhere a little more strictly to our by-law
which is to not ask leading questions and not go into and i did it as well because i saw others
doing it so i'm part of the problem maybe but uh can we not do that because these the delegates
are residents they're not our staff and let's not treat them like they're experts and everything
thank you and also let's not lead them to our own answers which are obviously what we want to say
anyway so thanks uh go ahead lynn you have five minutes just before i start i just want to say
two quick things i i apologize but i i did send my form in and i do understand computer problems
boy do i understand that so i just didn't totally love the impossible implied implication that
i made this up and said i submitted it and hadn't um i did it got lost i'm here it's fine um and i
just want to say i've timed myself reading this and i'm about exactly five minutes i think so i'm
just asking that if i go over by a couple seconds you just let me finish okay thank you
um i have delegated a few times essentially on four topics the undemocratic strong mayors
powers issues around development the need for responsible fiscal management and citizen
engagement i'm here today because this one agenda item covers each of these i'll begin
with engagement because it's pretty much a fluke that i'm here today at all normally i can't be
on a random tuesday in the daytime as a residence who are working or attending school can't be
but by chance i was free today if council cares about real engagement they should have regular
evening council meetings further in what seems to be too common this manner was matter was rushed
through to the extent that the vast majority of citizens would not know enough if anything about
it to come and delegate on it today anyway and certainly would not have had time to spend their
family day weekend in preparation i'm here because i happen to see something about it in the media
on friday by that time it was already too late to register to delegate by the deadline i happen to
be among a small minority who knows that i can register late and may still get to speak
i screwed that up slightly but okay most would not know this it's the oldest trick in the book
to release to release news one might not want the public to notice just before a long weekend
this is an extremely important issue at a cost of almost 100 million dollars over two years and it
is unacceptable for council to not have supported councillor nissen's request last tuesday to delay
this decision for two months he explained well his rationale that this time would allow for staff
and council to do fulsome research and it would allow for the gathering of opinions and feedback
from residents oh yes residents remember us do residents think that we should be the ones helping
developers increase their profits well since you haven't given us time to answer i guess you can't
say for this resident the answer is a resounding no and i expect that i'm in the majority i don't
believe there is any justification for developers to be bailed out of their obligations and costs
of doing business if the market isn't giving them enough profits for their liking then they
can stop building and sit on their investment until it turns around or they can reassess what
it is the public actually wants and needs and build those things instead more expensive towers
on burlington's waterfront for example sped up now thanks to the mayor's direction do nothing
to provide the affordable housing and the types of housing that families and young people want and
need it is not on municipalities or citizens to solve the complex issues surrounding the housing
crisis but it is sure used as a great excuse by the development industry and by governments who
decide for various reasons that they wish to help them build build build anywhere and everywhere
i'm gobsmacked that any of you would think is acceptable to transfer this financial obligation
onto an already overburdened taxpayer particularly in these times where so many are in dire straits
and whether this magical provincial and federal funding materializes or doesn't certainly you
don't know whether it will or won't in the end i will remind you that again there is only one
taxpayer so that all comes from us too regardless it is irresponsible to hand over our money and
hope that other levels of government may pay it all back and can we be honest enough to not call
it a freeze a freeze signifies that the rate charged last week won't be increased for two years
it doesn't mean their charges have been wiped out completely more misleading language there are many
other municipalities which have exceeded their housing targets without waiving development charges
being the first municipality to make a hugely expensive mistake isn't a precedent one should
want to set every dollar of ours that you hand to the developers is not only one less dollar in the
pockets of taxpayers it's much worse than that it's one less dollar that could instead be being
spent on far more important things and that is the same whether we are talking about municipal for
provincial or federal dollars the consequences are huge and cannot be summed up by staff members
producing a rushed report at the request of their strong mayor who holds the power to hire and fire
senior staff i might add that leads me to the undemocratic strong mayor powers which no mayor
should accept let alone use ever while i'm not surprised the mayor has used her powers in this
manner i'm really appalled that she has there's an old saying about how even the appearance of a
conflict of interest is one which must be avoided a similar concept holds true for the strong mayor
having unilateral power over staff members to which she gives directions the public can
never actually trust that the staff members are telling us what they believe or what they feel
that they need to say they believe this is as unfair to them as it is to the public it's one
reason the powers should not exist in closing it is disrespectful to your council colleagues and
especially councilman nissan for the mayor to have used the powers and gone over their heads
it is disrespectful to citizens that this is being done in a way where we are not being properly
informed and are not given the opportunity to be heard and in which even the most basic standards
of engagement seem to have been bypassed it is disrespectful to put the onus on staff to rush
through and produce reports and unnecessarily tight time frames it is disrespectful to every
other business owner in burlington whose profits are also likely waning in today's economy that
you've decided to bail out big developers with deep pockets as mayor mcgord was fond of calling
them so please spare me spare us the talk about respect respect is a two-way street thank you
thank you i'll look to the board to see if there are any questions
councillor currents thank you very much through the mayor you uh raised the theme of respect and
how that's um and trust and how that's identified under the strong mayor's powers over a long weekend
for a senior staff that can be hired and fired what would you imagine it must feel like to be
given such a directive on short order one that resulted in three times identifying that the
answer could not be provided fulsomely i think it must have been extremely stressful and unfair
i was i have seen a report which i will send you for your interest
where a journalist interviewed a bunch of municipal staff across ontario and
ensured their anonymous anonymity um asking what it is like to work in i mean it's probably now
with strong mayor and the results you know they were allowed to say whatever they wanted and they
wouldn't be identified and it's very problematic thanks very much and my second question is this so
from an engagement perspective had this gone through i mean right by this hour really we could
have been completed an agenda if it wasn't changed and municipal taxpayers would be on the hook for
the numbers identified in the report how might that have reflected it could have been done and
dusted by this hour right now the entire report that you're delegating to how might that have
landed from a community engagement perspective if this was if the report on the development charge
um waving was completed by this hour right now today and then it was promoted out to the city
how do you think that people would feel knowing that it was a fade to complete
oh they would not be happy not at all all right thank you
i'm not seeing any other questions i do have one for you and it's a question of clarity you
mentioned that there was a speeding up of waterfront development due to the mayor's
direction and there's been no such direction to speed up waterfront development so wondering what
you meant by that what i meant was that because of the direction that will encompass the projects
on in the football area on lake shore that's what i meant by waterfront i don't mean that you
specifically said i want it to be sped up but that will be the effect that by by including all
builds luxury whatever there's a it's a very strange irony because i believe you voted against
some of that uh but this direction will actually help speed that up
okay and you heard earlier some questions around a cap so that luxury units of any kind are not
captured would you support a cap to address that concern which most of us would support for sure
and i do my um thought really is i think similar to david's that i don't support
that i don't support um taxpayers paying for what should be the cost of doing business for
developers they should pay they should pay those fees period councilor currants
thanks very much and through the last line of dialogue it's raised some questions for me
and again my apologies for being sick on committee and also being absent any legal advice
on this matter i'm now hearing new things like potential caps i know that there has been some
community dialogue around if the development was issued in its its planning permissions by
way of a tribunal decision that it would not get you know a double bonus from the city by
by getting its development fees waived are you aware of any other type of criteria that that are
now being flown around that would be supportive or are you still in your stance that absolutely no
no development fee should be excused whatsoever no i but i don't believe they should be excused
okay thanks all right i'm not seeing any other questions thank you so much for joining
this morning we have no petitions the recommendations from standing committees
have already been referred and changed to a subsequent meeting we did want to deal with
the confidential items so i will ask that the confidential items be brought up and we'll
vote on those sorry point of order go ahead we didn't include petitions so that shouldn't be
discussed we have no petitions the whole section shouldn't even be spoken to it should be silent
don't even say petitions can i have the clerk correct that
through you mayor mead board sorry i don't understand um correct that i think we can move
on point point has been noted okay confidential items are on the board now are there any further
questions okay any comments on the confidential items
okay councillor currents i'm just a question to my colleague i believe councillor bentovania
wanted to go into closed on some of the closed items
i don't see a hand i'd like to go into close for all of the items on the confidential agenda on the
confidential okay then i will ask for a motion from you councillor bentovania seconded by
councillor currents to go into close to discuss the confidential items all those in favor we will
do we need a recorded vote on this okay over to the clerk for the recorded vote to go into
closed on this item on these items uh councillor golberth do not support councillor currents
support councillor nisan do not support councillor stolte support councillor charman
do not support sorry was that do not do not thank you sorry about that uh councillor bentovania
support and mayor mead work support that's for favor three against and that does carry
we are now resolving into closed session
you
.
!
I do have a motion to confirm the confidential minutes
and we'll take it in two parts.
So the first motion moved by Councillor Sharman,
seconded by Councillor Stolti,
that we confirm the confidential committee
of the whole closed meeting minutes of February 9.
Councillor Galbraith did declare a pecuniary interest
in one item, which we will vote on separately.
So that is not included in this package here.
So what you see on the screen is the items
and the minutes that we will vote on.
Okay, and that is a simple show of hands.
All those in favour?
Any opposed?
Seeing none, that does carry.
And now we will vote on the other item,
confidential closed minutes for which
Councillor Galbraith did declare a conflict.
He will not be voting on that item.
So all those in favour of the closed meeting minutes
for that item?
Any opposed?
Seeing none, and did note that Councillor Galbraith
did recuse himself.
Rise and report, we have nothing to report.
Instruction was given in the meeting itself.
We do need a confirmatory bylaw motion
to confirm the proceedings of this meeting
that has been moved by Councillor Sharman
and seconded by Councillor Stolti
that we enact and pass bylaw number 11, 2026,
being a bylaw to confirm the proceedings of council
at our meeting of February 17, 2026,
being read a first, second and third time.
All those in favour?
Is that a recorded vote?
Okay, over to you for the recorded vote.
Thank you.
Councillor Galbraith?
Support.
Councillor Kearns?
Councillor Nielsen?
Support.
Councillor Stolti?
Councillor Sharman?
Support.
Mayor Meadward?
Seven in favour.
And that does carry, and I now have a motion
to adjourn this meeting, moved by Councillor Sharman,
seconded by Councillor Nison.
All those in favour?
Show of hands.
Any opposed?
Seeing none, we are adjourned until March.
Thanks everyone.
Thank you.